ultimately is paid for by rate payers
and since our job is to represent the
interests of residential ratepayers
we take that seriously and I don't
necessarily think there's any
distinction in my mind between the
so the the handouts that I gave you are
going to be inscrutable unless I explain
them and I'd be happy to do that if
sure
all right if you'd like to start with
you presentation thank you
so we're asking the general court to add
one additional human being to our staff
making us an agency of six because I
would like to join my counterparts from
the rest of New England and devote at
least one person full time to Regional
electric matters the electricity Grid in
New England meaning wholesale
electricity markets and the bulk power
transmission system are operated and
overseen by a non-profit organization
called ISO New England which is subject
to Federal not State regulation and
because we have restructured our
electric industry and opened electricity
to competition at wholesale and Retail
this is where I would suggest much if
not most of the action is with respect
to electricity rates and electricity
regulation in New England and it is very
difficult and Arcane stuff uh ISO New
England is governed by two different
bodies one is a board of directors it's
a garden variety non-profit that has a
board and there is also a stakeholder
Advisory Board and I put the word
advisory in air quotes because it is far
more than advisory that board is called
that body is called knee pool and it
functions kind of like a big legislature
and um my office is actually a voting
member of knee pool and if you look at
the first the one page handout I gave
you that's just a schedule that I got
from ISO New England of all of the Nepal
committee meetings that one would have
to attend over the course of any of
those three months listed there in order
to be up to speed and uh diligently
exercising our vote in Nepal in March I
think there are eight days and these
tend to be either all half day or full
day meetings and what's discussed at
those meetings is very detailed
technical stuff that has to do with
economics and the details of how
electricity actually works at wholesale
the other document I gave you
is a memorandum from the New England
states committee on electricity Nesco
Nesco is the organization that
represents the six New England states as
sovereigns each state has a Nesco
manager our state's Nesco manager is
sitting behind me he's the commissioner
of energy Mr shacoin and what he I think
would readily confirm is that Nesco and
my office
complement each other I have the vote in
Nepal I'm a voting member of Nepal Nesco
appears Before ice of New England and
participates in Nesco meetings without a
vote but as the representative of the
states as sovereigns and the reason I
copy this particular Memo from Nesco for
you is really because I wanted you to
look at a couple of lines that begin at
the very bottom of page two and continue
on to page three and there you see
references to over 2 over 2.787 billion
dollars of asset condition projects
plus
3.255 billion more of such projects that
are proposed and if you read through
that memo and interpret it a little less
uh
how can I say this if if you read
between the lines of this memo and
actually see it for what it is what
you'll discover is that all of those
expenditures something like
six billion dollars in transmission
costs over the last few years are
essentially going unscrutinized by
anybody
and that is just one example of what is
happening at the regional and federal
level that has direct and serious
impacts on rate payers that nobody is
looking at and I want to send somebody
to all these meetings of Nepal and ISO
New England so that I feel more
confident that the interests of this
state's rate payers are being protected
and just for reference if you take that
six billion dollars and divide 6 billion
by 10 which is still a big sum of money
that's roughly New Hampshire's
um so I think that's the gist of what
I'm asking to do and it's the first time
I've asked either the governor or the
general court to grow the office of the
consumer Advocate and I think in the
circumstances it's a it's a reasonably
Modest Proposal
questions represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman so this um page
you gave us with with these meetings the
nine and March and so on
um which of those meetings would be
attended now
um without this extra person well right
now I rely on an outside consultant to
attend those meetings for me I share the
that Consulting team with lots of other
clients uh two of which are other rate
payer advocates in the region my
counterpart in Connecticut and Maine and
others that have interests that diverge
from ours frankly and I would feel more
confident and comfortable uh with my own
staff person there
um there is enough going on in those
meetings so that even if I sent a
full-time person in to engage with all
of this and still relied on those
Consultants there would still be aspects
of this that I couldn't cover as well as
I would like to where's the consultant
in your budget uh I didn't bring my
budget document with me but it is in the
Consulting
um
right
so
okay so this is only
so first of all this year last year you
uh we have two live Consulting contracts
and we are continuing to spend money on
them
uh but they were both uh I'm not an
expert on how the budget actually works
technically those contracts were both
approved in the previous year 2021 and
so I think that might if it says there
that we didn't spend any money last year
yeah further so so that line which was
Zero last year is scheduled to be 25 000
this year and then 50 000 each of the
next two years
right so
um that's less than what a new person
would cost yes
yes because my contention or my
hypothesis I guess is that there is lots
of work that is not being done by
anybody
meaning representing the interests of
New Hampshire rate bears at the regional
and federal level
ideally we would also be participating
in proceedings before the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission which is the body
yeah so would you be willing to have
this new person but not the Consultants
or not I would be willing to do whatever
you tell me you decide that the general
court is going to do but I would humbly
ask that you not do that we have uh
um
we have money in our Consulting and
litigation lines in our budget to help
us with outside experts because I need
outside experts to present expert
testimony at the Public Utilities
Commission and I have two in-house
analysts to do that in my budget but I
am unable to fill those positions at
present and if I continue to not be able
to fill them I do intend to rely on
outside Consultants to provide me with
that help
represents Sweeney followed by
camberells thank you Mr chairman thank
you for being here for taking questions
my first question I have for you
take the total sum of the budget you've
requested what's the impact on the
ratepayer to fund it if you were to put
it into cents or dollars of the year for
average
I think that our proposed budget is
about a million dollars a year in the
upcoming biennium and if you uh it's it
is a tiny tiny tiny ratepayer impact I
mean uh pennies a month something like
that what follow-up you had mentioned
this new position uh taking votes in the
New England ISO group
what informs their vote on the committee
are they bound to policies that we've
adopted as a legislature the energy the
10-year energy plan what informs how
they vote as an individual member of the
group I I would say it's both of those
things uh there is a provision in our
enabling statute that also appears in
the I believe it's the enabling statute
of the puc and maybe even the department
of energy that obliges us to go before
these Federal bodies and make sure that
the interests of New Hampshire's rate
payers are not unfairly subsidizing or
paying for the public policy uh
initiatives of other states it won't
surprise you I assume to know that the
energy related public policy of the rest
of New England differs pretty markedly
from that of New Hampshire and our job
is to defend the public policy interests
of New Hampshire and its rate payers and
so yes I am familiar with the 10-year
energy strategy and I do think that it
is part of my responsibility to advance
that strategy regionally and federally
and so we work in con officer with the
Department of energy and its Nesco
manager because although I'm independent
of the Department of energy I think the
interests of the state and its rate
payers are well served if we maintain
representative kimberles thank you Mr
chair
um as you said this is a very
complicated I haven't been on science
and technology and I understand the comp
how complicated uh this whole thing is
uh how come if we fund this how
confident are you that you can hire the
appropriate individual that will have
the knowledge to deal with this that's
an excellent question uh I labored over
this because uh you know there are
different ways of uh
creating new positions and I created
this new position as an attorney for
position I know that uh the state is
going through this big reclassification
effort so that attorney four will vanish
into Oblivion but I decided that my best
chance at successfully recruiting for
this job would be by having that job be
an attorney and I've seen I I I've been
to Nepal meetings and I've participated
in these forums personally and I think
the people who are the most effective
are the ones who are trained by lawyers
they can talk to the economists and it's
a little harder to do it the other way
and I've I've had more success
recruiting lawyers than analysts and for
whatever reason it might be because I'm
a lawyer and I can persuade other
lawyers that I'm just great to work for
I really appreciate representative
cambrell's being on this division
because
having the knowledge of science and
technology is I think pretty important
especially after listening to the debate
yesterday on all the other Science and
Technology bills but representative
people
hi uh welcome back um would you would
you argue that it is to the rate payers
great benefit to have an individual as a
full participant in these Regional
discussions
um so that the smaller investment for
this attorney could pay benefits for our
rate payers in the long run absolutely
that would be the guiding premise of the
whole thing and as I said at the
beginning every single one of my
counterparts in the region has at least
one full-time person dedicated to this
work I believe my counterparted
Massachusetts has has several and I
admire their work but the public policy
of Massachusetts is not identical at all
so without having a person there full
time for us uh
we could be affected in a negative way
because of all these other
countervailing issues and we're not
sitting at the table to present our own
yes that's exactly the point I'm making
and that's really the reason I gave you
that Nesco memo like it is my testimony
that there is six billion dollars of
past and future transmission costs that
are going into rates and being paid for
by every electric rate payer in New
England that nobody at any level has
scrutinized these are utilities that are
spending billions of dollars and nobody
is looking over their shoulders and
representative Weiler followed by
representative McGuire
thank you as an example of one of the
things that sometimes come to light
several years ago when the price of oil
was going up and we were getting more of
a break from
Hydro Electric
we discovered that ISO New England was
assigning all the breaks
and hydroelectric from New Hampshire to
Connecticut
even though most of the hydroelectric
was really coming from the Connecticut
River although it's the Connecticut
River with most the hydroelectric was
produced in New Hampshire
and so here was ISO New England giving
them the credit so our oil levels went
up higher and we weren't getting credit
for the hydro that's the kind of thing
that goes on if we're not watching so
anyway
you need somebody there to make sure
this doesn't happen
thank you
represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman so the other big
increase in your budget is on page 359
litigation which is going up 67 percent
are we planning to start suing somebody
that we're not suing now uh no this
comes up I think any time our budget or
the department of Energy's budget comes
up for some reason the the word
litigation appears in the budget when it
really means uh administrative
litigation in front of the Public
Utilities Commission
so why are those expenses jumping this
much I I I asked to increase that budget
as a kind of an insurance policy because
I can't seem to fill my two analyst
positions and I either need outside or
inside analysts to present expert
and and I can't I'm not allowed to
transfer the money that is allocated to
those two staff positions into my
consulting or litigation budgets uh so I
kind of have to make provision for both
sure
sorry so I don't see that you're missing
anybody in the sense that if I look
between 2023 salary lines and 2022
actuals
there's essentially no difference
the two positions that I'm talking about
became vacant in
September of last year and so we did pay
those two people through September and
they were uh I believe they were both
fully occupied in the previous year so
that's why they're not they're not
zeroed out either in the current year or
this is just a comment but it seems like
we're sort of double counting here right
we've got money for people and money for
that is unabashedly true I don't know
how else to do that in a way that will
allow me to continue to be effective I
can assure you that I'm not going to
uh I'm not going to do the same thing
twice I'm only going to use either
analysts or Consultants
is this a footnote type thing or I don't
know
um Melissa Mr Hoffman should we put a
footnote there's representative McGuire
suggested
what would you like the footnote to say
well I'm thinking suppose we we remove
the increase in this line but allow them
to transfer
or maybe some of the increase in that
line but allow them to transfer some
salary into
consultant
if there's an unfunded position you know
I mean an unoccupied position you know
something like that similar to the
Department of Corrections language that
permits them to use salary benefit money
for other purposes yeah they use it for
overtime but we could write something if
yeah something like that but then you
know we could maybe save
um 75 000 a year or something like that
out of the
representative Griffin has a question
thank you Mr Chan thank you for taking
the question
uh so you anticipate there's going to be
some unsp unspent funds at the end of
the budget Cycles yes when are those
unfun unspent funds end up
they stay in the pockets of rate payers
because what happens is our costs are
assessed by the business office of the
energy Department to the utilities and
the utilities then recover those costs
from customers
so
in that case I'm not sure we need a note
these these are not General funds
the the issue is
if we leave it this way he could if he
wanted to spend all of it
right but if we change it he has to
decide this or that right so
um
because he would have the authority to
to do all that spending
right so
Melissa Mr Hoffman could just just
prepare something and we can take a look
at it next week
yes what now would you like the language
to go both ways
so in other words uh out of tenants out
of
salary benefits into litigation
if needed or if circumstances change
would you like the ability to go from
litigation back into salary and benefits
all right we'll take a look at that not
that you need anything else to do but we
can take a look at the language next
week
I did have a question that's not
entirely uh Financial but
since you have become part of the
Department of energy which came about
two years ago in the budget
your you were administratively attached
to the puc now your administratively
attached to the Department of energy it
almost seems like a conflict to me that
you're trying to protect the rate payer
uh is there
any conflict that you shouldn't perhaps
be with a say the Attorney General's
office or something to protect the
ratepayer versus being
administratively attached to the
Department of energy that may not have
the same protection drive that you have
as a consumer advocate that's an
excellent question and I've thought
about that question a lot I've thought
about whether I should ask you to change
my administrative attachment and I've
decided that I should not if you look at
the administrative attachment statute
which is section 10 of RSA 21g you'll
see that it really is an attachment for
administrative purposes in the sense
that my my only formal relationship to
the Department of energy is I use their
business office meaning they create my
budget documents for me and they do all
of the back office functions that any
state agency needs and what the
department of Energy's business office
knows how to do that the Business Office
of the Attorney General's office doesn't
know how to do is has to do with that
assessment process they literally send
the bills to the utilities and the
utilities pay them because that's how
they're funded and that's how the puc is
funded and of course they're also right
in the building with us we're all all
housed at the Walker building on the
corner of the what used to be the state
hospital so so it's administratively
convenient and appropriate and it
doesn't otherwise entangle us with the
Department of energy or the puc since
the creation of the Department of energy
it has been very very careful not to
attempt to influence me and it certainly
doesn't purport to oversee me in fact I
think a lot of the time they would like
you to know very emphatically that they
do not take any responsibility for what
I do or say
so who hires you
um my enabling statute is RSA 363
section 28 and what it says is that
there's a body called the residential
ratepayers Advisory Board which acts as
a sort of a gatekeeper so my current
term expires in November and I have
asked to be reappointed and so in the
first instance The Advisory board
deliberates on that question and they
either will or will not recommend me to
the governor for reappointment if they
do not recommend me for reappointment
then I have to go somewhere else and
find a new job if they do recommend me
then the governor gets to decide whether
he would like to re-nominate me and if
he does that then I have to be confirmed
by the executive Council and if I am
turned out of office or just leave
office then the residential ratepayers
Advisory Board is tasked with
interviewing new candidates for the job
and their job then become is writing the
governor a letter with three names on it
and the governor is supposed to choose
and nominate one of those three people
that's how I originally got the job
all right tell you're a good lawyer you
know all the facts representative Weiler
who are the members of that Advisory
Board
uh that's another excellent question so
the uh Governor appoints three of the
members of The Advisory Board the
president of the Senate appoints three
and the Speaker of the House appoints
three and there are if you look in my
enabling statute particular
constituencies like the elderly and the
disabled who are represented on The
Advisory board but in Practical terms
it's really a discretionary call by
those three elected officials
I wonder who the representatives are now
well for example uh one of the new
members of my Advisory Board is a
gentlemen most of you are probably
familiar with his name is Neil Kirk and
uh representative Kirk I assure you is
an extremely active and Lively member of
my Advisory Board and I really enjoy
interacting with him because he he
doesn't take he he doesn't accept
anything at face value he is the patron
saint of extremely skeptical questions
extremely skeptical that's well put
uh so I'm grateful to uh it's actually
representative Vos the chairman of
Science Tech and energy who uh convinced
representative Kirk to accept that
appointment and then I think he
convinced the speaker to make that
appointment and it's been uh it's been
fun and and I think it's improved it's
made me a sharper rate payer Advocate
answering all of his questions and the
third individual the house member uh
well I only named one uh and I forget
who I don't really think very much about
who appoints which of my Advisory board
members uh one of the speaker's
appointments is held by our chairman uh
who is a businessman from Key named Tom
Moses I would just you I think
representative Weiler asks who are the
other State Rep was that's what we're
just looking for I thought you said
there were threes the speaker has three
appointments to my advisory
there are uh there's uh Jim Garrity a
former state representative is also a
member of our Advisory Board I think he
was also appointed by the speaker now we
can look it up representative it's on
our website yeah
okay
I thought if there was an opening maybe
representative cambrell's could fill
that
anyway uh one further question yeah I
just what are the other responsibilities
of the board in addition to appointing
or recommending you for appointment that
is its major responsibility the board
does meet quarterly and I I treat it
like a board of directors I I I pretend
that I'm an executive director of a
non-profit reporting to a board and so I
send that board quarterly a detailed
report I write along four Page Letter to
the board every quarter and I give them
spreadsheets with all of our uh
litigation or administrative activity
all of our legislative advocacy and all
all right so uh moving right along I'd
like to get an opinion from the division
about the additional person
representative Kimbrell's
well again uh thank you Mr chair
speaking from experience I've had a lot
of exposure to this department having
been on stne and I have to say that they
do an excellent job protecting the rate
payer and I'm also very pleased at how
you know they do defend our policy here
for New Hampshire and
um uh I believe this is a value
proposition that if we add the
additional person we may find uh
that some monies are not being spent
correctly you're talking billions of
dollars here and I think it's a value
proposition for us to put that person in
place
representative Weiler
well just a caution for years a lot of
agencies would put more people in the
budget than they actually had so we
passed a law that said
a Personnel costs including benefits and
and so on and part-time and full-time
could not be spent anywhere else in the
budget so if we if we have them going
back and forth the consultant may take
it but obviously if we put it in law
it's a law change but it would have to
be a kind of an exceptional thing
because it's normally it's not allowed
anyway I'm gonna go look on another
division all right you've caused enough
all right representative Griffin do you
have a comment or question yeah I
I feel very strongly that we should have
a voice on those voids
um particularly because
our Direction Maybe
quite a bit different than the other
states
and I think it's really really important
that we have
our own oversight on those boards and i
would support it I would support the
additional personnel all right General
consensus I see a thumbs up and we okay
all right we'll
suggest that when we go to the full
committee that you get a new another
position and we'll get a footnote uh to
address representative McGuire's
concerns yeah together with an hb1 yep
cut a little bit Yeah okay thank you
so the overall number doesn't balloon
yeah because I think your budget over
what was spent in 22 is about 35 uh 350
000 more so it's pretty substantial
increasing I know the rate you know we
say no General funds but we want to keep
the rates down even though it may be
just a couple of pennies but it's all it
all adds up in the end of course I
heartily concur as I have to because I'm
the ratepayer
all right well thank you very much thank
you
so next we have the department of energy
and I see the
folks out there if you want to state
your name please for the record
my name is Jared jocoin I'm the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of energy
this is our 341 I believe right on the
budget I'm sorry I didn't mean to step
on you there oh no no no worries uh good
morning Rory Patterson I am the director
of the administration division at the
we we don't have a handout for the
committee
um didn't know exactly how you wanted to
handle
um our requests in hb2 I can start with
the appropriation we we requested for a
regional fund
um but happy to take it line by line
um from the text of the bill
yeah we have a number of
we start on page 49 with section 139 and
it goes through page 51 down to section
147.
all right so we can check off 139 that
one forty 140 is also a consumer app
yeah so 139 140 we can check those two
off or we have a question yeah did you
see line 10 of page 49 so this is
already sort of a footnote yeah that's
you see in House Bill 2 line 10 page 49
yeah yes that would permit
the office to accept additional funds
through an assessment
um it's not quite the same thing okay
yeah yeah all right
I still need you to spell yourself sure
so starting at 141 I believe and page
49.
okay
um so uh We've proposed
um several just technical changes to the
parts of the statute related to our
collection of the assessment and this is
really to help us do that process more
efficiently
um and I'm happy to
turn it over to Rory she might be able
to uh talk you through that a little
better than I can so happy to do so I
oversee the Department's business office
which calculates the assessment each
year for regulated entities including
Public Utilities competitive suppliers
aggregators telephone providers and
um as Don mentioned earlier the
assessment is paid by ratepayers and so
it's very important to calculate that
correctly and to do so in a way that
we're not going back and doing
recalculations and rebuilding which
would essentially cost money in terms of
the um work of the business office and
cost time as well
um number 141 and I'm happy to take any
questions as I go along uh 141 what that
does is it really
um clarifies uh what year the business
office and the regulated entities use to
to calculate their revenues and and the
assessment right now there's a little
bit of a conflict between a section of
the statute that applies to assessment
exemptions and the statutes that apply
to calculations of revenues as well as
there's a conflict in the um a rule
applicable to the competitive suppliers
and the aggregators related to
exemptions and what we're trying to do
is align the year to the annual year
rather than to the fiscal year in some
instances
what this does actually is it gives the
business office additional time to do
this important calculation right now
when there are requests when when
entities provide us fiscal year
information they could be doing that in
July and right now the statute requests
the calculation and the issuance of the
assessment in August
um so by moving it to an annual year for
those entities they would be expected to
file their revenue information in and
around
um March or April which would give the
business office additional time during a
very busy period where they're closing
the books for the year they're doing the
inventory they're also in some years
um working on the proposal for the
Governor's budget uh like in this year
and so there it's a very intensely busy
period of time and more time is better
for everyone the business office staff
as well as a customer or the entities
because of the correct calculation
if you turn any questions
if you turn to um number 142 what this
does is it it moves the first assessment
um date and the dates that follow that
out by a month and the reason for this
change is that the actual expenses for
the prior fiscal year for the Department
is not are not known until after the
extended 12th which ends usually in Late
July and so the existing statute has the
deadline for the first assessment as
August 10th that gives very little time
to finish the calculation that's needed
um the next change relates to entities
less than ten thousand dollars and for
some of those entities it may be that
they just pay their entire bill at the
time of the first Assessment bill
um but it does just codify our practice
right now we issue the assessment for
the whole year and we continue to issue
what's due
um in the subsequent
um dates for issuing them and the or
only just um
relates to the payment one-time payment
after the first Assessment bill
any questions so far members I guess
representative Sweeney thank you very
much Mr chairman thank you both for
being here today just to make sure we
don't catch you guys in a headache the
actual putting the 15th of each month
into law if I were to fall on a Saturday
or Sunday would that create a storm for
you guys where you need an adjustment or
thank you appreciate that consideration
I think what we would do in that
instance would be we would issue the
assessment bills before the before the
weekend day or the holiday but I think
just uh having a change in a couple of
uh turning to I hope this is going okay
I haven't done this in a long time uh
turning to pay uh number one uh
um what this does is
it
um
what it primarily does is it enables us
to save
um thousands of dollars a year in
sending out the assessment bills by
certified mail we are not doing
registered mail I will acknowledge um
which is required by
um the statute now we use certified mail
and I want to say it's about eight
thousand dollars a year and what this
does is just modernize our ability to
send out the assessment via email or
regular mail and I presume
um the practice I guess would be that
um the postmark date would would control
in terms of the deadline for the bill oh
actually it's the due date for the bill
and by stating a due date for the bill
it makes it clear when the payment is
due
um rather than having it within 30 days
so the assessments you're speaking of
have you increased these assessments at
all in the last year or two or ah that
that's a very good question and they're
fairly consistent in the twelve thousand
dollar or I'm sorry 12 million dollar
range
um they've been consistent
um year after year
uh number 144 uh what this does
essentially as well is
um what I said earlier is just change
the um
change the calendar uh you change it to
calendar year and not fiscal year
so the division we would like to check
off a few more here uh
and it was at 144.
are you okay with that thanks it's just
technical yeah
Melissa Mr Hoffman also
the big one now yeah now the big one
that gets our attention
and for that I'll turn it over to the
commissioner so I don't have to do it
okay thank you Rory
um so in 145 establishment of the
regional energy advocacy fund this
relates to the conversation you just had
with the consumer Advocate
um
in RSA 374 F colon 8. just like to read
the last couple lines it
provides you sort of the charge we've
been given in statute as it relates to
Regional energy issues says the
department shall Advocate against
proposed Regional or federal rules or
policies that are inconsistent with the
policies rules or laws of New Hampshire
in its participation in Regional
activities the commission and the
department shall consider how other
states policies will impact New
Hampshire rates and work to prevent or
minimize any rate impact the commission
or Department determines to be unjust or
unreasonable
and as the consumer Advocate mentioned
earlier
um I serve as the Nesco manager for New
Hampshire
um
for the consumer advocate he has a vote
at knee pool where he's asking for that
additional staff resource to help with
that
um
our need for this funding is when there
are and the consumer Advocate did an
excellent job talking about transmission
costs and all that's being planned and
what could be on the horizon as it
relates to cost for our ratepayers
and currently we have two positions at
the department that work on wholesale
Regional issues Dan Phelan who is our
director is here today
um and we have two positions right but
when it comes to resources to do this
work if we have to make a filing at ferc
um a challenge something at the federal
level as it relates to transmission
costs in particular
um there are times when we really do
need additional analytical support that
we we may not have those uh that
expertise in the agency we tend to be
um as our team does a great job though
we tend to be more generalists um on on
these issues so the the support of fun
that we can draw on to hire the needed
analytical support or contracts that
need analytical support it's very
important
um at ferc uh the Attorney General's
office would represent us
um but again it would be very important
to have that technical support
um and we need that funding to do that
so that's
um high level what this request is about
um it again relates very uh closely to
what the consumer Advocate is requesting
representative cambril so you're my new
expert on this stuff so any thoughts or
it's right in line with what the
consumer Advocate does except it's the
department of energy and I can under
certainly understand that
um where there more more of their people
are generalists why they might need an
expert in this particular uh for this
particular type of thing and it is a big
dollar there's a lot of money exchanging
hands here the you know again the
billions of dollars but
I'd like to hear other people's thoughts
too on it though representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman thank you again
for being here so I so when we're
talking about the the billions of
dollars and trying to find
because it's not recoveries in the sense
that we would with other departments
where we might have been wronged in the
past and we get a lump sum back we're
looking for future savings for the
ratepayers correct okay yeah and and
these um Regional and at the regional
level at the federal level as it relates
to cost allocation
um you know
a lot of these potential transmission
projects are driven by the policies of
our neighboring states and um you know
we want to make sure that we are
adequately protecting and representing
the interests of New Hampshire repairs
um in all of those proceedings
and one follow-up thank you and so so
the general idea is that while we don't
know exact dollar amounts but we're
putting 250 000 from the ratepayers in
the hopes of protecting the ratepayers
from more than 250 000 in future rates
that's correct that's correct I presume
camber else thank you Mr chair that was
exactly the line that I was going to ask
um so have you done any projections to
say to maybe to kind of make us feel
better here what the what the return on
investment would be you know if you
looked at it in those terms what do you
think potentially we could save the rate
payer if we invest this money Dan could
give exact numbers but I think you know
we'll be looking at tens of millions of
dollars
um
or more he's telling me um it could be
in the hundreds of Millions
um
an additional cost
so we were to fund this would um would
there be maybe a report back to the
legislature a year from now two years
from now if in fact you know will you be
tracking that that we'd be happy to
report on that
um and and would be happy to report
um in conjunction with the consumer
Advocate if you're open to that I think
we're working on these issues closely
um so I think we would be more than
representative McGuire yeah thank you Mr
chairman
um why are we doing it this way rather
than adding to the consultant line
directly in house bill one in your
budget I think I'm looking at page 341
uh class item 046 Consultants where you
currently have zero so I mean this is it
seems like a weird way to do it
well I think having a dedicate what
we're looking for is a dedicated fund
um
that will support this effort
um we believe in clearly the governor
believed including an hb2 that it was
important
um that we uh establish a fund that's
dedicated to this
yeah I I didn't hear a reason there I
mean
this is to hire Consultants you have a
line there's a budget line for
Consultants that has zero
what if it had 120 250 000 you know what
I mean it's
it it it's a great question but I think
um establishing a a a precedent
um for us as a new department and the
important work that we do long term I
think it's it's uh it it's good to have
something that is actually a stake in
the ground that we are we're making an
investment in protecting our ratepayers
at the regional level
sure uh if I if I may just add something
uh and it did most of the
um expertise that the department would
file uh would request from ratepayers
are related to the costs of consultants
and dockets and they would be done
through this special assessment but when
the department needs consultation
consultants for broader public policy
issues
um those would not necessarily be
recovered through the assessment so I
just wanted to to note that those
assessment funds may be used for the
broader like renewable or offshore wind
or things that are not directly tied to
something that can be special assessed
it's an excellent point thank you
yeah I guess I don't understand that so
you're saying money in house bill one
you can't spend on these items
um no sir let me explain why I don't
like this because when you create a
dedicated fund it for us it becomes out
of sight out of mind you know we don't
look at the the balance and all
dedicated funds of which there's a lot
right we look at this book every two
years and so that bring that's what
brings it up to us to to budget right
that so so doing it this way
this is a fund you get to spend however
you want to spend it
and we'll never see it again you know
unless you say we need more into it
right but but if it's in the budget and
it's a regular item every year then
I think back to to Rory's point about
not being able to specially assess the
utilities for this um that is one
important I think argument for this
being its own fund
um I can't specially assess eversource
for instance
um for this work that we're doing
all right other further questions on
are you all all okay with the 250 and
creating this fun representative cameras
yes thank you Mr chair again I I believe
it's a value proposition for the
ratepayer at the end of the day so that
would be and again I I don't like
spending money and but uh this is a
complicated issue that's why
representative McGuire you probably
didn't understand the answer because it
is very complicated uh but I I would I
everybody else
okay okay
and 146
I guess we're going to win 47 that's uh
creating what general counsel yes so so
the general counsel that position does
exist and has existed but in the last
um budget for uh uh
22 23 we the position existed there was
some back and forth in the budget
process last time about where the
general counsel position should be it
ended up landing at the department where
we believe we do need a general counsel
um so we have a general counsel he is
with me today so the position exists
it's funded we just want to make sure
that it's in the statute for the
department and that
um I have the ability because it's an
unclassified position I have the ability
to um appoint that individual
just adding that language to the statute
I believe that's everything
thanks Mr Hoffman
so now we I guess we'll turn quickly to
your budget I did see a couple of things
that caught my eye but we'll
think you start on
while members are looking for
at your budget I just had a question on
141 the number of positions it shows you
going up from three to six I guess you
could tell us what those three
additional positions might be that's at
I believe
um and Rory can correct me if I'm wrong
I believe those are the full-time
temporary positions that we created to
administer some of the new federal
funding that we're receiving as a result
of the Federal Building
infrastructure funding and iija and Ira
I saw a lot of federal money for fuel
assistance was like 30 million yes we
would also to help in that line as well
um so we have not we have not requested
full-time temporary positions for LIHEAP
but we have for our weatherization
assistance program which is receiving
um compared to what we usually receive
considerable increase in funding over
the next several years
so I'm pretty sure that but I I'll have
to double check with the business office
and um I can get back to you on that on
those positions but I believe that's
what that is
all right
further questions from the division on
the budget uh
why you're all looking I had a question
on uh site
evaluation
the authorized for
23 was 286 000 but I see in the next
years it's uh other funds so these
assessments will be to people applying
versus any general fund money because I
think when this whole thing was set up
General funds were there to get you
started so we're
going away from General funds and into
other funds is that right I believe so
but I I don't necessarily want to answer
for the SEC uh the um the the chairman
of the Public Utilities Commission
chairs the SEC and they have an
administrator so you may want to double
check
um with them but I believe what uh how
Mr chair
Mr Hoffman there's a footnote
below that account yeah it allows them
to return to the fiscal committee
for General funds
now remember we gave them some funds
that get started and I think so but I
was just curious whether they were just
all completely moving away from General
funds and then just having an assessment
on those applying for a site evaluation
permit
all right well I guess that's what our
memories that's correct or well we can
any further questions with the
Department of energy
I'm not I don't want to rush anybody
representative McGuire yeah I have a
question on page 356.
your
[Music]
um
transfers to Information Technology are
going down in half we don't usually see
things go down when the information
technology
that's a good thing though thank you for
catching did you have a project that the
the finished or something like that
um
that's a very good question it may be
related to our appropriation when the
when the department was created
um uh there there were um
uh several projects related to our
website the creation of our website and
a new website for the commission as well
I'm not certain I can get back to you on
that
okay and the other question I have in
this general area of this is
administrative support
right the number of positions is
declining by a third
but benefits and so on is increasing
um
or at least thing maybe is staying about
if if there's fewer people there should
be fewer
um
that's an excellent question I would
need to get back to you on that okay
I think you were fortunate because you
did your relatively new two years old so
you get all new computers to start off
so hopefully that doht line will remains
low for the foreseeable 10 years perhaps
everybody else seems to be always trying
to catch up at least you started off
with new equipment
and I know that dyt works with you know
obviously the needs they determine much
any further questions uh
sorry a couple of Thumbs Up Everybody
okay to move along and maybe you can
just get that follow-up information to
all the LBA folks but
I don't see any need not to just check
the department of energy off as well and
are we okay with that
all right thank you very much sir thank
you
yeah thanks you too
be a good day for us when this is all
commissioner arlinghaus you are
microphones help don't they uh I'm
Charlie arlinghaus I'm the commissioner
of administrative Services who are you I
am Sheri Rockburn and I'm the assistant
commissioner
um so we have on your agenda it lists
the things we're going to mention to you
but we're happy to talk to you about
anything
um I'll show you the classified pay grid
the unclassified grid the pay warrant
for the hp2 pay Race by branch and then
we'll talk about the upgrade to the Erp
system uh somebody and apparently the
it's the guy with the tie asked about
um
diagonal pay I'm sorry that's
disrespectful because the honorable man
with the tie
um
yes
um and so the
yeah
oh that was really poorly thought out by
didn't help at all
um so so the diagonal equity which
exists in the system and and somebody
noticed with the unclassified system
that it doesn't exist and the answer to
that is
yes it doesn't exist
um
uh so in between the two you can see the
diagonal on the on the classified grid
and it's as people probably know when
you get a promotion let's say for the
sake of argument you were
you applied for a job and you're
currently let me see if I can do this
right you're 27 step five let's just say
and you get promoted to a 29.
the way we actually promote you as you
go you go diagonally down to where you
are so you would go down to 29 3 which
is diagonally the same and then up one
and that's how we determine your new
salary
um uh too much detail for you to know
but it's sort of fun so you hear anybody
ever say diagonal plus one that's what
they're referring to
um the classified distribution this came
up a couple of times with questions
somebody said how many people in what
step and all of that and um this is data
that we publish annually in the
Personnel report how many people are at
the maximum step how many people are in
the period where you have to wait two
steps
um I think this came up as a result of
those some of the questions when we
talked to full fiscal
and kind of where people are just gives
you a sense where things are
then slide page five shows you the
current unclassified grid
um
somebody asked me why why is this not
why is this goofy I think goofy is the
right term
um and I say goofy because you know in
the classified system
you know it's roughly four percent
between step eight and step nine and
it's roughly four percent between labor
grade this and labor grid that and
there's a it looks very thought through
and mathematical
and this looks haphazard the gap between
some steps is you know two percent and
some steps is eight percent or some
grades
and I think it was developed haphazardly
and periodically back in a very long
time ago
um
when they did raises people focused on
the classified system and unclassified
was an afterthought and then things were
added and changed in the last 20 years
there's been Equity
um to do what's compression issues but
it wasn't always so so there's no
diagonal equity
surely yes believe it or not we have
like a lot of people watching and people
have asked the question about
unclassified classified maybe you could
give just a brief overview of the three
different areas so
um in the state system classified
employees are are what we think of as
state workers almost every state
employees they classified
quote Civil Service employee and it is a
it is a system that's developed a civil
service system that was developed in in
you know in every state and in our in
our state and it goes back to the 30s
and 40s and was standardized in in 1950
and it is it is meant to be essentially
all the employees and it's why sometimes
we talk about people being paid hourly
because that system is based on hourly
rates you know whether you make
um twenty six thousand dollars a year or
you make a hundred and six thousand
dollars a year you're paid as a hourly
for 37 and a half hours there's some
schedules where you're paid 40 hours but
generally
um for 75 years 37 and a half hours is
our base schedule and that is basically
your basic state employees there are two
groups that are exceptional to that one
is the unclassified system which
um 50 or 80 years ago were called state
officers
and were spelled out it was the
treasurer the Comptroller the it was
essentially agency heads and deputies
that system has evolved so that instead
of being 40 people it's 350 people I
think it's something like 384 positions
out of 12 000. but so you know the the
bulk of state workers both part-time and
full-time are paid under the classified
system the system that categorizes
everybody efficiently there's a separate
unclassified system
um those classifications are done
through a legislative committee jcec
it's called
as opposed to the division of personnel
and all of that and it's it's typically
leadership positions there's some
nuances to that I get like almost every
every commissioner and well actually
every commissioner and agency had
usually their deputies and usually
they're division heads are in that
system
um 30 years ago
uh Terry Morton got permission to create
about 90 of them at HHS
that run a range they aren't necessarily
all leadership positions but usually
it's the leadership of departments are
unclassified which is a salaried
position
um and the rank and file are classified
there's a third group of people which is
non-classified and you might think of
that as much more strictly political
appointees
um which are a separate category under
under flsa the federal rules so the
governor's entire staff is
non-classified these are not necessarily
budgeted by position and are not
necessarily budgeted by salary
um I I like to say not doesn't exactly
work this way but for example the
governor's office has given a dollar
figure here's a half a million dollars
for your people you could pay one person
a half a million dollars if you wanted
wouldn't operate well but you could or
you could pay everybody next to nothing
and there's no restriction on that it's
just you you do it and you do your rules
legislative employees are typically
non-classified positions although
there's some exceptions to that and
their legislature has its own separate
grid and things like that but
non-classified there are very few rules
around
except the rules that affect everybody
those also
also are traditionally appointed so
there are point of positions either
through a governor Council process and
that's how the individual ends up in
them or a commissioner or agency had
would appoint that person into that
position so those also fall under that
and the classified is where most of the
bargain positions are
and there and the other point about
non-classified is you are you are
permitted legally to have almost no
protection for them right so in theory
and that's why we talk about political
appointees a governor
um the speaker maybe the speaker of the
house could say to his chief of staff
you know come back Monday
um
not not best practice but um and I'm
sure he wouldn't but technically there's
no protection you don't have to give
notice you don't have to have a reason
you can just do whatever you want
because it's a political job
um unclassified there are some
protections and government Council
positions have one set and other
positions have another but if you look
at page seven which is which is which we
use to talk about the pay raise
distribution and I'll go back and talk
about page six it gives you a sense of
the scope
think of legislative as not governed by
by most of the state rules they have
some of their own rules judicial has its
own sort of set of rules and if you look
at the dollar amounts of the raise
multiply that by 10 it gives you a sense
of how much that is and how the Lion's
Share the executive branch for example
almost entirely is classified
in that system I'm going to come back to
this in a second but flip back to page
six if you will
how is the pay raise budgeted and this
is one of the questions we got
the pay raise is budgeted by funds we
figure out how much a pay raise is going
to cost and then we apply a fund mix to
it to figure out how much it has to cost
by fund because what the legislature
does is budget what the government does
if you will is budget by fund and so if
you have enough General funds and not
enough liquor funds that's a problem and
and the funds tend not to be fungible
versus each other this is a long this is
a complicated process that we try to
refine every year to get it just right
and to make sure that we're budgeting
the amount of money that needs to be
budgeted but no more than needs to be
budgeted in order to pay for the pay
raise
um and so the budget document
historically has always had the pay
raise budgeted by fund
so that um although the The increased
cost of salaries is going to be about a
hundred and one million dollars
um almost 45 of it is General funds and
so you don't end up budgeting 85 million
in general funds or 65 million in
general funds you budget the amount you
need so that's the budgeted number
for each year and that's the number
very helpful
oh I wanted to add no this is very
helpful the only other thing I was going
to add is as Charlie as a commissioner
talked about in terms of you know how we
budget this is also based on or I should
say it's not based on total positions
that are authorized you know we really
look at field positions we look at
vacancy rates we do a projection of
where we're going to be we obviously as
Charlie said only want to give money
where it's needed we don't want to over
budget for that so that's just an
important thing as we drill into the
numbers is that it's really looking at
your actual employees that are that are
going to be staffed and and that's a
historical thing where legislators
legislatures in the past have said why
are you setting aside money we're not
going to spend we're you're forcing us
to spend
um let's just say we budgeted every
every position instead of the positions
that will be filled you would end up
budgeting let's just say for the sake of
argument 10 more and someone says why am
I why am I depriving myself of 5 million
a year to to address priorities that the
legislature identifies when you know
you're not going to spend it because
there's always going to be a vacancy
rate whatever the range of it is and so
that's something that that has been
hammered into
um administrative Services budgeting
people for many many decades by
the collective you so to speak
um if you look at the Grid on page seven
that just gives you an idea I know
there's a lot of the question about
what's what's in the legislative branch
what's in the executive branch what's in
the
um what's classified what's
non-classified there are other way other
ways to parse this out but this is sort
of the big picture for you and and we
did General funds and all funds just to
give you a sense and
um I hope that helps you and that that
gets at some of the questions you're
asking
okay
um
so he got a seven
so if we go to page 72
that's where a lot of this starts and
those sections are on page 72 through 75
that's sections 195 to 209.
that again starts at 1.95 through
209 are we okay with that it's a lot of
money but I think the Department's done
an excellent job in Breaking this out
it's one of my questions I was curious
and the breakdown because other
divisions are looking for money
thank you Mr chairman um I see the
unclassified table in the in the house
bill too but I don't I'm I mean the
class yeah I'm classified I don't see
the classified
too so there are um there are
technically something like 30 or 35
classified tables and and historically
um many of them are in the various
collective bargaining agreements and
it's you know the correction officers
are paid this way and the law
enforcement schedule and all those and
and historically the the legislature had
adopted one table
and then there was kind of a wink like
you'll adjust the other ones the same
way right but I never said that and we
didn't do 30 so we in uh I think it was
two years ago in the legislation we uh
we amended um that section English RSA
99 but don't hold me to that to say that
administrative Services shall adjust all
the pay tables accordingly and so
um but the
the so the pay tables don't have to be
in statute on the unclassified table
unfortunately is in statute and so you
have to adopt it
it's not a yeah it's not created by the
formula and there's only one right so
instead of 35 or whatever it is
depending if you count schedules and
really
interesting
no I I just wanted to be really clear so
this is an across the board 10 raise on
all the branches
right
yes
and we just we haven't seen nobody's
Left Behind no we haven't seen the
um technically for legislative employees
my understanding of the process is that
um
the legislature has to vote separately
to adopt the raise for legislative
employees and I believe that fiscal
adopts one group of employees and the
facilities committee adopts the other
group of employees for the legislature
and those committees my understanding is
technically you can do whatever they
want
play the facilities committee is meeting
the morning of March 24th and that's
when they're going over the legislative
budget which is sort of it's sort of
outside of the time period that we have
to be done but just
to make that note and then just follow
so the unclassified positions are all
the leadership positions and their rate
of pay starts at a much higher level so
the 10 percent is
a bigger the um the the unclassified
schedule uh runs from AAA on up and what
I do mean to imply is that most
leadership positions are unclassified
but not every unclassified position is
in leadership so the the A's are about
the equivalent of if you if you compare
and um the
um
at the sort of mid-range the highest
classified schedule
is
um 35s are about a GG so with the
exception that
I think everyone here knows that it's
difficult has been difficult for years
to get employ some employees who accept
a promotion
if they're classified moving and
unclassified because you give up over
time and you go from a 37 and a half
hour schedule
where you are literally legally
prohibited from working a 38th hour I
mean my first three months on the job we
wrote somebody up for working
um which was very
hard to because they you know if you
work I must pay you and if I'm not
budgeted money to pay you you must not
work or I'm going to commit an illegal
act under federal law and so so that
there's a there's some there's a
compression issue in state government I
think everyone knows that representative
McGuire's question yeah so I assume it's
not 40 hours because there's a half hour
lunch is that the idea
no no it's in a in fact on a on a
on a 30 I believe on a 37 and a half
hour schedule it's a seven and a half
hour day but seven and a half does not
include you let's say you work uh let's
just say for the sake of argument an
eight to four schedule it's eight to
four but you have a half hour lunch you
are contractually required to take a 15
minute break for which you are paid the
half hour lunch you are not paid
and if you work eight to four Thirty and
take an hour lunch that's okay too
right but so therefore I think the
answer is yes as opposed to no but all
right
the the main problem I have but that I
what I mean to say is the difference
between those on a 37 and a half hour
schedule and those on a 40-hour schedule
is not that one of them gets a longer
lunch
okay
um
the main I don't have a problem with
this raise thing but I just think
I don't know if we would need to be
mindful of it but on page six the people
were we're gonna make the most difficult
um
the most problems for it to me seems to
be division two
because Highway fund Turnpike fund those
are not sort of variable Revenue sources
right they those are very fixed you know
so many so many cents per gallon of gas
and so many uh you know registration
fees and stuff like that and and we're
adding 20 million dollars 20 and a half
million dollars of Highway fund expenses
by approving this right and so I think
they're going to be in trouble but we
haven't heard them I would encourage you
if you look at the governor's executive
budget summary one of the things that
includes in it is Surplus statements for
all of the funds which Sherry's going to
point out now all include the pay raise
in them
and all include a positive balance
so and the only other thing I would say
is that if you work at Fish and Game
you're probably also having trouble
hiring
and your workers are also having trouble
keeping up with inflation and and
it would seem weird to deny them
well it's a follow-up to representative
McGuire none of these pay raises were in
any of the budgets that we've reviewed
so it's they're they're not they're not
in the budget itself but because they're
a separate House Bill 2 item
um it means that there is money there is
money available and and they would not
have been
you know the the governor legally has to
present a balanced budget and and if you
if you look at it it's not just balance
but it's balanced
um not even what Surplus revenues that
way in terms of the pay raise so
although as you know we've the Ways and
Means Committee has found he was a
little too optimistic in his Revenue
numbers
yeah I don't have to do resonance
anymore
too lucky
um are there any more questions
represented grassy not to put you on the
okay uh representative evil did you want
to hold back on the legislative portion
just because we haven't seen their
budget or
well it's a thought I don't know what
the rest of the division thinks I mean
the the
budget Isn't So under the statute the
the uh facilities committee is the one
that sort of reviews the legislative
budget and blesses it
um
and that's on March 24th in the morning
so
we won't have their feedback for our
review so I don't know how that works we
do have their budget in here the
proposal
you know we just saw everybody's aware
we have to have everything done by
Tuesday so the LBA can work on it and uh
get it out for next week because we have
a session of course Wednesday and
Thursday represents Sweeney thank you Mr
I just want to make sure we're I'm
thinking of the right conversation we're
having are you talking about the
legislative pay raises or the whole
legislative branch budget well
point
all I was saying is it's hard to approve
the legislative branch in some ways
until we know what they're doing so
I just put it out there I just I'm not
sure the division realized that
facilities has to approve the
legislative branch budget and we won't
have a benefit of having a conversation
with them before we have to
give our blessing to the division one
recommendations is that right Mr chair
that's correct yeah so Mr chairman if I
if I could offer I don't know if this is
helpful or not but um
historically with things like the pay
raise what what has happened is that
um the legislative finance committee can
approve the money being made available
should the facilities committee Etc
decide to Grant it I'm not aware of a
situation where they've decided not to
Grant it in the past I don't want to you
know pass performance as no indicator of
future results but um but I would say
that that one of the things the
legislature could consider doing at
least on the pay raise portion I don't
want to speak to the rest of it
um is you could go ahead and pass it and
so the money would be available for them
to know that they could decide one way
or the other to accept it or reject it
and that way you're not
um you're not doing a half your budget
now in that sense yeah just a follow-up
to that the fiscal committee like
approves all the LBA adjustments and pay
races specifically that's where that
makes sense to me because otherwise
we're just going to have to come back
whatever folks think I just wanted to
make sure we were aware of the deadlines
were involved with
yeah it would be nice to get rid of a
large chunk here if we could today I
think
we all recognize that all the state
employees need a pay raise I I guess my
question initially was that as far as
those leadership roles what was the
impact because obviously they're the
well except for Charlie and the most
compensated as far as state staff but um
certainly all the classified employees
really deserve a raise and
I think mostly a classified employees
are union members and they did negotiate
in good faith now Charlie just a quick
question are there any unclassified that
are union members they know like in my
industry the railroads that many people
that become managers hold on to their
union rights and pay the monthly fees so
they can still be part no and not in the
state in the state system they aren't
then and they're in fact there are a
number of other positions typically
um some senior managers and people are
involved directly or indirectly in the
bargaining discussions and and data
process who are so-called confidential
employees and therefore not eligible to
join the union
but um so none of the unclassified or
Union knowledgeable
um most of something like 92 percent of
the classified are eligible
okay so representative McGuire are you
prepared to move like all those items
from 195 through
209 yes
um
so I just in general I mean the amount
of the raise is similar to inflation
right the the there's no question about
that and also the the constant refrain
we hear from people is we can't fill
positions right well that's a sign that
we're not paying enough right not that
we're paying too much
um there's only very few agencies have
come in and said well yeah all our
positions are full I mean I heard that
once maybe in the past month right so so
yeah I think these are reasonable all
um any further discussion everybody okay
with that simple show of hands for those
sections 195 through 209 all right
thanks that's uni nms
and while we're not far from 194.
uh that's parking and Concord I think
there were some questions we didn't
check it off
I guess it's um
I'm I'm sad to say I don't have Hospital
2 in front of Meek and then is there any
chance somebody has an extra copy
is this 50 000 for parking yeah there
was a note that I wasn't enough or
something it was like
50 000 but that was only half what was
yeah I enough is one of those questions
so
um right
um
most most state buildings have parking
near them somewhere
um almost all of them have parking lots
attached to them certainly the campus
does in Hazen Drive does Pillsbury
Street does South Street does
um but if you happen to work downtown in
the State Library the doj that will soon
be torn down or the annex
almost nobody has parking and so for
decades the Union contract included in
one of the subunit agreements the admin
Services subunit agreement which is not
terribly controversial we get Park money
for parking and Boots
um but
um included 50 000 for parking this was
moved into House Bill 2 instead of the
CBA because there have been years when
the CBA is in Evergreen
and that provision was not in Evergreen
and we asked for it to be moved for this
reason that well there's a well there's
a thought that some things shouldn't be
an evergreen because it encourages
bargaining I don't think I don't think
the fifty thousand dollars for a handful
of employees who have no parking space
um was really moving the needle one way
or the other and so for the from a
bargaining standpoint it's not a big
deal from uh from a few hundred people
who are like trying to figure out what
to do it's it was a big deal so we put
in House Bill two instead of in the
Union contract that's all and it's been
50 000 for a few years
so we're okay now with 194 the language
and well so we can check that off
194 Mr Kane when it says as appropriated
where is it appropriated
so that is in a um in a dedicated
account well I shouldn't say dedicated
in an accounting unit that's in our
budget the accounting unit um is called
special disbursements and there's a
class line directly in-house Bill one
for that I don't have my full budget in
front of me but I can give you the page
numbers the department of the Commission
in the office of the commissioner yeah I
think we brushed across it that's why I
had a memory of fifty thousand dollars
it's the same accounting unit with the
governor's transition fund the money we
pay for the Concord Fire Protection
I think we pay EAP out of that
accounting unit yeah yeah it's not that
it's not dedicated
um it's on to age 50 yeah yeah it's on
page 59 of your um of House Bill 1 page
59 the account is called special
and as you get there so once again page
towards the bottom is a line that says
class 213 Concord fire and Municipal
Services it's 175 000. 50 000 of that is
to the city for parking cards
um they average about 140 in um for a
person and the remaining 125 is a
payment that we make to the city
um
to assist with uh fire police other
services that we that we may need from
them
um but it's not a direct bill or
anything like that that's just also been
um it's been the same number for a
really long time how much is it per car
parking nights now
um it adds up to 50 000 though so if you
were to use your parking card so I'm
very fortunate and feel guilty every day
um that I have a parking space so
um and and it's and it you literally
feel guilty every day because people are
walking and you're like hi I know you
have to park in the garage or on the
street and it's snowy and I feel bad but
um
uh if you were to use your card every
day to cover the hours that you're there
for the entire day would last you about
further people tend to use it on snow
days we try to have a uh when the
legislature is not using store Street
and
and Terry's willing
um we um people can park on store Street
and we try to have a free parking option
and run a shuttle and for the other 50
weeks what do people do they either
store street during the off season your
off season
um some of that they pay out of their
pocket or they Park in it used to be the
Old Highway Garage on
um
store Street and we would shuttle them
although we're now running that out of
South Street the building on South
Street that used to be the hospital
down by Tuckers but
as somebody said to me you know if you
if we if you're an accountant and you
take a job at Edmond Services you're
actually taking a pay cut
and and I'm like I know just can we not
from a budgetary standpoint you can't
cover 52 weeks it's just not
all right so we we're okay with 194
okay
I'd like to move if we could quickly to
sure I should have one more item on hb2
and that was
um their upgrade the appropriation for
the upgrade of the Erp system it's um on
page 70 of hb2 section 186 and 187 it's
a 7.8 million dollar appropriation in
um of my handout for you slides eight
nine and ten are about this if you want
me to lather
um I'll try to be quick because I I know
we don't want to go from parking to
Parks without a pallet cleanser
that's good huh
um uh this is for the ER Erp uh fiscal
committee approved money recently and
I'll explain quickly uh what it is uh uh
page eight what is an Erp
enterprise resource planning is a term
of art it's a computer-based integrated
system of an organization's business
prophecies processes HR payroll
financials
Etc it's every all of the software used
to run the operation of the business the
business in this case is called the
government of the State of New Hampshire
and it's it's that it's it's the uh
everybody on every desk every Financial
Manager every HR manager Etc
um traditionally uh it's been on premise
and uh all of these things are moving to
the cloud
um New Hampshire first is what we call
ours uh apparently that technically
stands for something but don't ask me
what it is because no one can no one can
remember and I think there might be two
s's
um but um anyway it's a Statewide system
and our current vendor is called infor
which is a which is a large National
software company some of its competitors
are places like Oracle and workday and
names people will have heard of when we
bought the system originally the the
company was called Lawson you may have
heard that name
um infor bought loss in about 15 years
ago
um so page nine is why an upgrade
um
uh the costs associated with our 14 year
old 14 year old that's a long time in
Computer World on-premise System uh
continue to rise and we struggle to keep
up with the latest supported version
um
as of April the current version will no
longer be supported think of it think of
Windows 98 if you will it's okay to run
Windows 98 as long as you don't connect
to the internet but um you're out of
luck because they don't support you
um and that's kind of where we are so
the state has three options at this
point we reached an inflection point and
that's why we're coming to you there are
three basic options one is to do nothing
although the state has occasionally
taken this task in the past Dennis
Goulet routinely yells at me when I say
this is one of our three options because
he said you know that's not really an
option I said I know but we did it
before and he said but it's stupid we
can't do that I said I know but it's one
of our options is do nothing so this is
me telling you it's not a great option
um the other two are to reprocure a new
Erp system to go out to bid uh solicit a
bunch of vendors and reprocure a new
system three is to upgrade the existing
system that we have this is often the
question you have on upgrading systems
of any size it's a big deal because this
is so big
um
reprocuring a new system we could get
bids we might change vendors we might go
to workday we might go to Oracle we
might go to I don't know all the vendors
in the system anymore I know PeopleSoft
got bought by somebody if anybody
remembers PeopleSoft
um but um
uh we believe that would be a much more
expensive proposition and would require
significant change management if
somebody else uh about the system uh
Idaho is doing this and and it's more
than 100 million
um although probably we would be
significantly less than that even though
we're a similar
size-ish of state and state government
as they are
um because they're they're abandoning
some other Legacy systems but it would
probably be
um the last time Dennis Gillian I talked
he said he said definitely 2x like two
times as much but probably 3x or 4X
um in terms of total costs and the other
option is upgrade the existing system
with infor which is the path we're
taking
that that passed the costs are on page
10 and the discussion of it is on page
10. it's about 25 million and again we
think the we think the other of the
all-in costs are about 50 million
um in February fiscal they approved 15
million of arpa funding which the arpa
Gods granted to us
um and 15 million not on the assumption
that 15 is all it would cost but that
we'll do 15 here and we'll do the rest
in out of hustle 2 Appropriations in the
budget
um
upgrading upgrading really is cost
effective but it's a it's a once every
decade or so cost and it's not something
you can account for in your operating
budget and it's frankly brutal on the
capital budget too you know the capital
budget if you tried to like go well I
had this thing and it's only 25 million
in the capital budget everyone in that
committee has a stroke it's um it's it's
just very difficult to do that they're
like like we could do a couple of roofs
it's you know it's like a courthouse and
then some if you will
um and so this is one of the few times
where we might even be able to do this
so
um it's about 22.8 million that's why
we're asking for 7.8 on top of the 15
and I would just note the project is not
scalable it's a question people ask well
can we just do like half the departments
in the state it's an all or nothing it's
an Enterprise System not a some agencies
system and uh and I'll note from the
standpoint think about it this way
one of the major components of this is
financial you know payroll and and
State's finances the state has one set
of books
not multiple sets of books we have one
set of books even Al Capone had only one
set of books in fact I think that's how
they caught him
um what you'll see operationally is
three separate contracts one is a
contract with infor and that's to review
the processes build test train Etc
enforce the software company that's the
Microsoft if you will
um Axiom
um Axiom is an is an implementer they're
an infor partner but they're a separate
company uh and they're doing uh
simultaneously we're doing a transition
to what's called workforce management
which is a new time keeping system from
what we do today and this is something
that's been been working on or trying to
work on for five to six years
um and they'll compete that process
workforce management is an integrated
part of the info Cloud Suite products
and third we'll have an ivnv vendor
independent verification
and validation vendor and that is
um You probably saw this with the rims
project at dra you want somebody
independent to tell you whether this is
going well or not otherwise you have to
rely on me
or the people doing the work and we're
always going to go no it's really
actually going much better than it looks
like and you don't need that you want
someone to say it is going about how it
looks like and they need to you know get
their rearing gear on it so okay so
that's the Erp funding
so representative McGuire has a question
yes thank you
um how much do we pay ongoing for
maintenance in this area and is that
being changed by by up doing this
upgrade um I think in the in the coming
year we'll pay roughly a million and
they and after the upgrade will pay
roughly
um I can get you exact numbers roughly
1.7 and we'll have a 10-year contract
we could have a contract with an
escalation of zero but it's a yeah right
but so in a sense we're going to pay 70
percent more just for maintenance
even though we have a brand new system
yes it's
um and frankly it's moving from uh
moving from an on-premise system with a
maintenance contract to software as a
service and it it's actually what's
happening with with everything in the
you know think of it think of it think
of it this way you don't buy Microsoft
Office anymore you buy a subscription to
Microsoft Office so will we save on the
hardware costs
um we will have a modest reduction in
what we spend with doit and and some of
the uh servers and all that and I I mean
I've looked at all of those numbers and
um
we will have a modest reduction but I
don't want to pretend to you that we're
going to save so much that this is a net
Financial
bonus it's in that Financial cost
right so I think we should approve this
the they've already spent two-thirds of
all right commissioner you have a pretty
significant ask elsewhere too it's about
six million dollars of the priority list
that we saw
uh on the 24th of February so
would you
rather see this 7.8 million
or are there other assets that are
equally as important on the other six
million dollar side
um the 7.8 is an ask that I cannot
operationally do without
okay so if it's an either War there's
not there's not a choice the division
does have some significant wiggle room
we have like 84 million and one bill
that's we have enacted on we've got
invest with 30 million so we do have
some
wiggle room so I guess representative
McGuire is putting forward the 7.8 at
this point representative Griffin
or if okay show a hands we're okay with
that
from scratch okay
um we'll add that sorry Mr Kane
[Laughter]
every time we add something we get an
email from Mr Kane telling us to be
cautious yeah
I'll just note that that was in the
all right so we can quickly move then I
know Joe's got to get out of here at 11
30 Joe yeah uh if we could look quickly
um I think I discussed them in in some
detail and I you know I think each of
them is sort of a standalone
um I don't want to say that that any of
them is a package
and um you know what we do and why we
need them
and uh I would just say operationally I
do understand that if the
um if if it's one of those things
nobody's getting nothing then good we're
fine with that but if you said to us
what's um
you know what are your operational
challenges this is this is what they are
and you know the one thing that is that
is very much a one-time spend as opposed
to ongoing operations is the uh uh the
maintenance funding the 3.5 yeah and
then the only other piece that that is
one time and and by the way in the 3.6 I
think it is is scalable
and as is the 1.2 and and that's about
moving costs when people are moving
buildings you know we have a system
right now that that is
um
budgetarily based upon a presumption
that no one ever moves anywhere
and um
which is a bad presumption if you want
to fix buildings
and so uh uh you know it's very hard I
had a discussion with a very small
agency the other day who said well you
know our lease is expiring and we want
to move here and I said how much money
do you have for moving costs and they
said we don't have any
and I said and and the the director of
the agency said
couldn't you just pay for it and I'm
like I'd have to ask my wife I don't I
think it's going to work
but it's um but it it's a it's an issue
you do get an A for humor you know I I'm
not sure that my entire staff would
agree with you on that but thank you so
the pleasure of the division
again I know we do have some wiggle room
but
we'll have to come back and look at what
we may have to Chisel away on as far as
the items that we have not
touch to represent McGuire yeah let me
just ask the building maintenance fund
uh sorry the building maintenance fund
does it have a certain amount it's not
elapsing so it has a certain amount now
how what's the throughput kind of of
that um the throughput of that is meant
to be
um let me do a 75 cent a square foot
charge and I think it's roughly
um 2.8 5.6 per biennium
does that make sense and we're we're
holding off on projects this year until
we know what's going to happen in the
budget and whether we have to stretch or
not stretch
so the 5.6 per biennium this would be in
addition to those things
okay to to deal with maintenance that
hasn't been performed but should have
been the state and should have been as a
by the beholder question the state if if
I did a real deferred maintenance list
it'd be about a billion dollars
and so you know we hope to do two or
three million a year we're not really
keeping up
we are going to
um in the course of the next six months
is to a
professional survey of every building
and identify with a with an independent
you know large corporations do this a
lot in the University system I think did
it where you have somebody come in and
look at all your systems and say end of
life five years from under life 10 years
from under life you know when when
should you expect to do something so we
can be strategic instead of just
whatever happens to get funded okay
thank you we have a long history of
deferred maintenance here at least the
time I've been here it's always we'll do
it next budget cycle and I think we've
so you are ready to move all these along
representative McGuire right
[Music]
yeah sure on the division of Enterprise
App Management how does that relate to
Erp and that's who runs the Erp
it used to be called fdm which I think
stood for financial data management
because the data was much more than
financial
I think in the 80s it was just financial
data and that's when they created the
name now it's called Enterprise
application so they managed New
Hampshire first and it is it is it is
that organization
the line item that you see in front of
you is not related to the project itself
it really is just a keying error that
occurred in in the budget so if you
looked at your budget page it looks like
there's a Federal grant that's coming in
and it was just it was just keyed
incorrectly so that one is is a fix that
we're asking for
well because we're under kind of a
deadline here we either need to move a
couple of these or none or we could give
the department some wiggle room was
giving them a flat amount and they could
decide whether they needed for human
resource coordinators make it two and
one purchasing agent or
and give them that Latitude
to make that decision with just a sum
amount but again looking for suggestions
from the division represent McGuire all
right I'm
I guess I'm in favor of the big items
more so than the than the positions
because the positions often are
um unfilled already there's other
positions right I mean so you know
there's places to add people and just
because if we have this position that
puts money that's may very well not get
spent so
so you're looking at the 1.2 the 1.2 and
okay are we I think we'd be we'd be
um operationally very satisfied with
that
all right the rest of the division
members okay with it I see thumbs up
okay
thank you uh appreciate your efforts and
again uh
respect your advice and
all right Melissa and Mike
if those three items to add in and we'll
we could if people are up to it we could
certainly move but my guess is we'll
just come back Monday okay Monday at 9
30 and we'll hear those two retirement
bills on Monday
yeah I'll have a better get that did you
because like Janet
he wasn't in there but I can run in and
schedule them yeah go over and make sure
those two are scheduled
and also put Tuesday as a word
because I noticed it wasn't in the
calendars I want to make sure I'm
working an amendment to reduce the 84
commissioner how are you I'm wonderful
how are you good thanks like if you
could state your name for the record and
identify the colleague next to you that
would be helpful thank you uh Sarah
Stewart commissioner of the Department
of Natural and cultural resources and
I'm with Chris Marino who oversees our
office of administration
I just want to remark that the last time
we were here representative McGuire you
were wearing a Valentine's Day tie yeah
and this time you're wearing a St
Patrick's Day tie so I feel like we're
always celebrating a holiday when we're
at least it's not April Fool's Day yeah
yeah
um
so we were before you on February 10th
and I provided some overall remarks
about our budget that was before the
governor issued his Budget on February
14th
um and uh you know the headline is we're
very happy with the governor's budget
allocation for this agency we oversee
five divisions as you'll recall Parks
and Recreation the division of forests
and lands the division of historical
resources the State library and the New
Hampshire State Council on the Arts and
we feel that um uh most of our requests
for this next biennium have been
fulfilled in the governor's budget so
today we're happy to tick through
um that budget with you answer specific
questions
um perhaps before we do I'll let Chris
Marino just share a couple of small
items that uh
were not covered in the governor's
budget but we wanted to bring to your
attention
all right fire away good morning thank
you uh just choose two items that uh we
wanted to mention that we're we're not
covered one in in one case is just a
small increase in our utility line uh
for our service operations account for
150 000 and I will specify that uh
provide a written specification for you
and the other item is a doit position
this is a position to support our agency
it is a management position
um currently the setup we have right now
is kind of left over from when we were
dread as you may recall we were split
into two separate departments however we
still have one individual trying to uh
do Management Services for both
departments and it has become a matter
of
uh really just not being able to
maintain the level of service that we
need so we have sought to add a position
we've conferred with doit on this they
are in support they are in agreement uh
however it was not uh included as part
of the uh it was not accepted as part of
the submission with the governor's
budget we'd like to go ahead and request
to have that added to our budget as well
and again I'll provide detailed
information on the particular position
uh and the the funding it would be
General funding which is primarily well
it would be an allocation of mixed funds
when our department primarily General
funding but some other uh percentage of
funds from agency income since it will
be servicing the entire department now
your budget starts on 601 could you tell
us for the benefit of the LBA and
ourselves where that line would increase
on what page perhaps sure uh well the it
would increase within accounting unit
29.82 which is on page
I apologize
the print went upside down
uh be page 603
excuse me so under accounting unit 2982
so what we'd be doing is adding an
additional amount in that
account to uh cover the cost of an
additional position salary and benefits
for an additional position
and how much was that it's estimated to
be approximately
combined salary and benefits a hundred
and eight thousand dollars in 24 and 114
Mr chair
Mr Hoffman we have that on the second
page of our additional request doat also
asks for this is one of their items okay
a little more duplication
all right thanks for pointing that out
Michael
do you want to clarify
uh that was all I had for additions that
was all we had
um there was one question that had come
up uh in the prior session we had back
on February 10th uh there had been a
question uh by
might have been representative McGuire
um in any case it was a question about
the uh allocation of funds within the
Commissioner's Office the question
related to why there was a portion of
agency income and increases uh so what I
wanted to do was clarify unfortunately I
was not able to make it at that time so
I wasn't there to assist but essentially
the commissioner's office is comprised
of a mix it's
we have within the Commissioner's Office
functions such as the conservation plate
fund which is nearly a million dollars
in other funding we also have the design
development maintenance Group which is
90 funded by uh agency income as well
and we also have in that figure for the
Commissioner's Office the indirect cost
which is allocated by the administrative
Services as part of the Statewide cost
allocation plan so that figure is
identified as other income in that
accounting unit as well so there are
other functions there's also I'm sorry
the Bureau of historic sites as well
which is also currently funded with
Parks funds
all however we do have language in House
Bill 2 that would draw a warrant to
allow that function to be put back under
a general fund a fund source which is
where it always has been except excuse
me
correct
so hopefully that clarifies
the mix of general and other funds
within the Commissioner's Office yeah I
see you do have a number of issues that
we haven't touched on in House Bill 2
summary we should go to House Bill 2
and we have the Christa McAuliffe which
falls under your
jurisdiction and some others so Mr
make sure I'm looking at a couple but
should we start in the looks like that's
on uh page 32 section 83 yeah okay
yes and I believe that the governor's
office is finalizing their committee
membership
list for that
um it allocates I believe is it a
million 500 500 500 000 to commission
um
uh an artist which would go out to bid
to develop a memorial statue to honor
Krista McAuliffe on state house property
and I would be on that committee uh as
well as I believe the commissioner of
Das or designee
um
some members of the public and appointed
representative McGuire I do recall you
had a question on this about maybe
raising private funds or
yeah I don't remember it too much I mean
I
I heard it's hard to
um
to justify this in my mind
is is this something that
um a charity could be made to to create
there is language I believe in the
executive order that allows for
um private donations which is wonderful
if you recall the most recent statue is
of Governor winant which is over in
front of the State library and that was
um that was a
product of much fundraising the
experience I heard was really tough to
be honest
um and so I think that the I I think
that the governor wanted to make sure
that it that it could be achievable by
giving it this allocation and also
welcoming
um
donations from the public what was the
cost of the Winans statue and when was
it spent
so a language in section 83 gives the
authority to raise money to give some
whatever start the process
the actual Appropriations the negative
four
so we could act on at least getting the
things started in 83
and then we can move to 84 and discuss
whether the state wishes to put any
money okay it's a project we all came
so the appropriation you have a
suggested amount organization McGuire or
do you don't feel we should fund it
can I just ask what you would estimate
the cost for it would be so we haven't
had this kind of just popped in front of
us
um so we haven't had time to you know to
get any cost estimations for what a
current day
statue artist would charge
um I'm told it would be north of five
hundred thousand dollars considering the
you know if we're having it on a slab of
marble or Granite you know there's a lot
of things that need to go into it uh
previous to Governor winant statues have
not been put up recently on the state
house there are six statues including
Governor weinert
um and I think before the that most
recent one it was like a hundred years
before so I think prices have changed
since then I'm guessing
um but uh part of the the job of this
committee will be to do some of that
research and come up with
um you know the parameters of What
expenses this should be
is the committee itself uh entirely
volunteers and this money is strictly
for correct okay
yeah maybe
um
I don't know I I'm still I I would like
to see that there's significant
fundraising from others before we add
um taxpayer funds so
so I would just move to remove section
84.
comments from the division
representative yes thank you Mr chair I
agree with representative McGuire uh
again I think it's the
we need to get more details let the
establish the com the committee for them
to come up with some figures and some
numbers
um
do we have any idea about any of the
costs for the design for the governors
Winans
statute out there there's any numbers on
there you said it was like a million for
the whole I can get those I'm sure
they're all documented and since it was
a recent project I can find those for
you
no and that could be the starting point
of this committee's work
yeah speaking for myself I would agree
with representing Kimbrell's and McGuire
but just one person here any other
thoughts
yes represent kimbrells thank you Mr
chair yeah what I was thinking was if
they at least had a night and I the
rough idea of what the design element
would cost maybe we could fund that
portion but I wouldn't fund 500 000
without knowing so if they could say the
designer would cost twenty five thousand
dollars whatever then maybe we could
appropriate that amount but the 500 is
an odd starter for me
all right everybody okay with that
all right uh Melissa Mr Hoffman please
all right there were some others that I
saw that caught my attention Mr Hoffman
and a couple more in there
um
appropriation for the State Library
97 and 98 or the next page 30 page 36.
I'd like to discuss that yes thank you
so the State library is an historic
building I hope you've all been there
um and it it will never be fully a
climate controlled facility for the
preservation of the books and documents
that are charged uh to the library from
for management and protection
over the years we have
um you know quarantined some of the
special books in a more climate
controlled area of the library
um but but it would be a huge
undertaking to
um to fully uh
redo the air quality in that building
many many libraries in New Hampshire but
also across the country are recognizing
that in order to stay relevant they need
to
connect more with the needs of the
community this is what a lot of your
local public libraries have done and
very successfully and so the State
library is looking to to become more of
a public-facing facility state-owned
facility here right next to the state
house where fourth graders show up
almost on a daily basis these days and
where the public comes from not only all
over New Hampshire but all over the
country to tour our state capital
uh the idea here and what we've already
begun is working with uh Das and the
Department of Public Works division of
Public Works who have assigned a project
manager to um to work with
um some professionals who can assess the
stacks of books in the library currently
and determine which ones we we are by
RSA required to
maintain for the public which ones might
be donated or outdated and which ones we
should move to a climate secured storage
facility
and tag with an electronic number that
can we can then you know find it easily
as needed for the public it would not
compromise our customer service it would
not compromise the interlibrary loan
system function Etc all the all the
expected customer service projects that
the library undertakes it what it would
do is free up some space in the actual
building and allow our agency to do some
programmatic work to showcase our
archeology lab findings to have a
gallery night For Young Artists in New
Hampshire to you know a variety of of
valuable experiences that our agency
would like to fulfill in a more
public-facing way
so the governor allocated the million
dollars to take this first step which is
hiring the professionals to assess the
spatial
situation at the library with the books
and then actually do something with
their recommendation which would be to
take out some of the books and put them
in climate-controlled storage that can
that can be managed by our library staff
and free up that space in the library so
this is a continuation of the work we've
initiated
questions for the commissioner
representative McGuire where is the
library in house bill one
um
and you'll notice
there's the general fund thank you the
general fund component
Accounting in a two five five one
okay and then the other substantial is
um
two million I'm on page 664. so the
grand total for the State library is
roughly two million dollars a year
of General funds
and there's a similar amount of federal
funds
right yes although that is uh
yes approximately two million dollars in
general funds yes
so this would be like a 25 increase
in the cost of the library this would be
very separate from their day-to-day
operations
um sure this would be a special project
that I
believe would then serve beyond the
current scope of work that the library
is physically able to conduct at their
building
what is the cost of this storage
do we yeah go ahead so our state
librarian Michael York has been talking
to other communities that have done
similar projects
UNH has did this a number of years ago
so he has been working with DPW to to
share some of these estimates
um the the million dollars is on the low
bar I think of uh of the technology
portion of the project however until we
have this assessment of needs
we're not I don't know how it's how
large a project this might become my
hope is the million dollars will get us
moving in this direction and we can do a
phased approach that we can work through
some programming
um a pilot programs at the State Library
while we've moved some books out there's
going to be some painting needs and some
you know maybe let new lighting or
whatever in some of the spaces of the
library that currently just hold books
so there's a lot of moving Parts but the
hope is not to let this project stall
after we get the DPW project management
assessment achieved we want to keep
moving forward
yeah let me ask you a slightly different
way how much of the million dollars goes
to the consultant who will assess the
book none
we already have the money
to pay for the Consultants who are
already
dpws already doing an rfq4 and will you
digitize all the material that gets
stored not necessarily we are always
digitizing
um our our books and paperwork and
records at the State library and we give
out a ton of Grants around the state for
local libraries to do the same but a lot
of the books we are going to say is
books and will be then stored in a
climate controlled facility but we do
regularly constantly digitize
but we're not going to digitize
everything and
that's that's just an ongoing
maintenance project the digital
digitization so so if someone had a
request for something that was stored in
this facility there's a way to go ask
the amendment to go remove it promptly
okay yes
yeah I I just don't know how to how do I
evaluate
what I'm getting for a million dollars
in the sense that you know it's not you
didn't say a thousand books will be
stored or uh you know some kind of I
would say more than a thousand books
um to free up the space of the State
Library I would love to take this group
on a field trip at the State library and
do a tour to show you the um untapped
opportunity that I believe exists in
such a beautiful building
um not many people
go from their car into the State Library
they go to the state house but they
don't and that's a shame and I think
that it's a beautiful State Building
that our just to start with our agency
could bring to life with the talent that
we
um that we have in our in our agency and
beyond that we could expand but I think
it could be a wonderful place that's you
know open week evenings for uh for the
public to enjoy various programming
foreign
question I have on this uh are there any
of these books that you're looking at
that are at risk oh yes of damage and
could be lost absolutely follow through
with this absolutely that is that that's
sort of the the patchwork quilt approach
has been um doing okay at the State
library but it's not uh we're not
confident that that approach is truly
um protecting
the most valuable paper products that
are in that building so yes they are at
risk representative evil please thank
you I'm
I'm word of this section and this
appropriation
um I I know what the State library has
been going through just from the public
works side of things I also saw
a real mess that we got into with the
state archives neglecting some of our
historic documents
um I think there are many valuable
things that should not be neglected
the library is beautiful and it also
sounds to me like you're trying to bring
its programs more into the 21st century
so that you can reach a greater
population within the state so that they
can benefit what's in the in the library
so I especially since you've started the
process again because of what I've seen
with the archives the patchwork quilt
effect doesn't really work and I think
we should appropriate the million
dollars
yes representative cambrell's please
thank you Mr chair being that we are a
finance committee and I know you can't
probably put a price on these these
Treasures that we're storing but if you
were to put sell these on say a private
Market what would be the worth of all
these these these words millions and
millions of dollars we have books that
are you know signed by authors from a
long time ago there's a ring in the
library that is like jeweled and amazing
we can't we don't have the ability right
now to properly show showcase it
publicly it'd be nice to have it under
like a museum quality box for the public
to see but we can't we don't have that
ability at the State library right now
so good question there's a there's a lot
of very valuable Treasures that are sort
of hidden and tucked away and our
mission is to provide access to these
um so I don't feel we're fulfilling our
mission by tucking away a lot of the
stuff that we should Showcase in a safe
and probably one of the two
Representatives that have spent a lot of
time over in the library
doing research
it worked out well because
between committee meetings if I had a
couple hours to kill I could go over
there
it's a beautiful building
um
there's there's unbelievable resources
in there I'm sure of it
I just shared a representative
but why is
concern about getting my hands on the
million dollars I'm saying
where is it going or what are we getting
for it and it's to me it's a big number
I know it today it seems to be a
millionaire and a million there but I
there's representative McGuire thank you
there's a different million dollars that
I want to remove
um from this area so maybe we should
consider that one first
and then come back to this one it's
public television oh
yeah
public television
well I I would just say if there's that
concern there's a difference between
zero dollars and a million dollars I
mean maybe we could come up with a
some amount because I think excuse me
we're hiding our light under a bushel
basket here and it's almost like our
state museum in a way
I just think that we haven't put enough
money into the wonderful value that we
have there I'd like to stick with the
million but I don't think we should zero
this out if there's concern about it
well we just we just removed 500 000
from the McAuliffe line we could
compromise to a half a million dollars
would that be okay with everybody or
7.50
representative Griffin for those who
don't know he's quite a historian he's
got like millions of license plate well
hundreds of thousands probably right
could have a license plate yeah there
you go that's what I kind of thought
put them in somewhere in the in the
belly of that building
is all the original listings of
of who who
owned what car yeah in the registration
numbers
it was originally state law that that
had to be all published
and I'm pretty sure that
they all sit down the belly of the
building somewhere so naturally
the uh the federal government passed the
law and like the seventies that
restricted access to some of that
information so I have my own private
library of it you do bring up a good
point though because there is a basement
and a sub basement at the State library
and the State library is located on
Spring Street and it's named Spring
Street because there is a spring and we
have
that as a challenge as well that at that
building so to have a thorough calling
of the of the the books and and the
valuables you know the there's there's
books there that are you know 1957 birds
of Africa
and then next to it is you know the town
records of Peterborough so we we could
use
um the professional assessment so that
we can take what we want to preserve for
future generations and and keep it
accessible and get rid of some of the
the stuff that
you know we we are not the the RSA
doesn't mandate the State library to
maintain and then we have some of a
blank canvas in some of the space in
that library and that's where I get
excited it's not just a million dollars
for a box to put the books in it's a
million dollars that will allow us to
um
to connect with the public and that's
represent grassy please yeah I've I've
been through this before in the city of
Rochester we've had numerous document
City documents that were stored in a
sub-basement area and when we went down
there thinking that everything was fine
it was in very difficult shape and one
of the things in order to be able to
um to to to save those documents the
cost was far more expensive in the long
run
um to save them than it was if we had
preserved them in the short term and
that's why I think this you know this
million dollars or you know something
that's closer to the million dollars is
probably something we should look at
because if we don't in three to five
years they're going to be back here and
it's not going to be that it's going to
be a million dollars it's going to be uh
oh we need 10 million dollars or these
documents are just going to disappear
so we've seen have gotten to a point
that there's some support for something
now where did the million dollar
piece come from is that did you get an
estimate or is that something that you
folks just put together yourselves so we
when we had the chance to talk to the
governor's office about this originally
um we shared and don't have it in front
of me and I apologize we shared examples
of other local libraries throughout New
Hampshire who have gone through a
similar process
um I believe golf sound Peterborough
just said an addition but that's not
exactly what we're talking about Michael
York went through and he estimated
somewhere between 8 and 15 million
dollars if we were going to do it all at
once
based on the recommendations that we're
already paying for for a professional
assessment to take those recommendations
and achieve everything all at once
I like the million dollars because it's
significant enough that we have forward
momentum on this and we can
um take the recommendations that we're
going to get from the consultants and
have a real serious conversation with
you know go out to bid request for
qualifications type of company to help
us establish the next step
um so it's lower than what we believe
the overall project would be but it gets
us I think to continue the movement
towards the end goal
so somebody like to move an amount
please
I'd like to move 750 000 plus tour
okay it's been moved and second is there
any discussion on the 750
000 in a tour on probably April Fool's
Day right so McGuire so
so a show of hands if you're in favor of
the 750
All rights Union Yes okay is there
anything else uh Melissa Mr Hoffman
for them and House Bill too yes I think
um page 85 sections 266
there's a state Historic Site funds
appropriation
so this is an item that we brought to
your attention when I was here on the
10th
since its conception the Bureau of
historic sites has been generally funded
that was a strategic decision to make
sure our historic sites the maintenance
and the accessibility didn't fall below
um
and then when we had to
cut the cutter budget
um one biennium ago we did not want to
cut the funding for the his the bureau
so the parks
um
Parks fund
allocated money to to maintain the
bureau it's staffed the it's we're
working on some really exciting projects
from the arpa fund to make improvements
uh and it would be great that uh to go
back to its original funding intent
discussion division members
representative McGuire okay yeah so
more specifically how are you spending
this money
so if I could clarify the Bureau of
historic sites as the commissioner
mentioned was has always been General
funded for the reasons she stated uh
during the pandemic crisis uh there was
of course a lot of concern over how that
might impact things so we were
prescribed at that time to cut our
general fund budget by 15 percent
in doing so we had to take some pretty
drastic measures one of those measures
was pivoting to continue to fund the
Bureau of historic sites using Park
funds in order to sustain it to keep it
moving but certainly is not an ideal
situation so this is It's been
maintained this way through the biennium
we'd like to get it back to the general
fund Source uh sourcing that it had
originally in order to continue to
protect the priorities that are set for
the Bureau of historic sites so the
figure that is in hb2 is an estimate of
what it would cost to continue to
maintain the Bureau of historic sites
moving forward but are these positions
and so on in House Bill wins
yes so all of the everything that would
be covered is identified in house bill
one the only difference is in house bill
one it's funded with Park funds however
we were seeking to have that all right
let's see it in house bill went okay
foreign
total and currently is in other funds
budget so the idea is to Pivot that back
to being funded with General funds
no this is um
I don't know if it's why does
why does the benefits line jump so much
is certain positions becoming permanent
uh no typically what happens are in this
case what happened was there was a
change of personnel the prior individual
who was in that position did not have
benefit costs
whereas the new individual that came in
incurred a different amount of cost
based on the plan that is for their
position so it has as you know the costs
are pretty significant between
plan differences so that's primarily
what's driving that that substantial
increase
yeah I mean it's more than the salary
uh well there's also the benefit line
also supports the benefit costs for the
temp labor which is the class 50 line
gotcha
so
that's built in there as well
additionally there is also the addition
of a class 59 a full-time temp
so that is also a factor uh in
contributing to that increase in the
benefit line as well all right thank you
so I think those are further questions
on Section 266 we okay with that
well we're letting them spend Parks
money on Parks and not on this
right so
the parks will get suspend a little more
but they're saying that it had been they
were saying that it had been 900 000 up
until last biennium when when it was
funded with Parks money
and now it's back to where it always has
been so you know I would I would say
considering the unbelievable amount of
use our Parks have gotten during covet I
think they really need the money too so
the primary reason why there's an
increase in in that number is related to
the conversion of full-time temp
positions uh that is what they call 90s
so typically they're budgeted each
biennium they're full-time but they're
only Budget on a biennial basis within
our Park system we have a substantial
number of those positions we carried
them that way for for many years many
bienniums uh it was decided in this
biennium to strategically to to go ahead
and convert some that we have kept for
quite a long time in that capacity it
has been determined obviously these
positions are needed uh they are filled
every biennium going back
potentially some of them up to 20 years
so we thought it would be appropriate to
go ahead and convert them to permanent
classified positions so it would
essentially just be a wash removing them
from the full-time Temp and instead
making them permanent classified
positions of course the permanent
classified position count appears on the
budget the full-time temp count does not
so you would you don't see that that net
effect
yeah um well with one exception uh we do
have we did put a request in for uh
three new positions and at the same time
abolished positions as well to keep the
count correct essentially deciding there
are certain needs that our department
has certain classifications that are
necessary uh where others are not so we
were able to to to change that to uh to
net that out however we did request a
a full-time uh park ranger I'm sorry for
a stranger my apologies and also uh we
were approved for a position in our
prioritized needs for the arts division
so there are actually technically an
increase of two positions uh for the
okay any questions on further on the
budget
representative McGuire yeah so I asked
the LBA to make an amendment to House
Bill one
um which I guess he's Mike is reaching
oh yeah
representative McGuire liked to speak to
his Amendment yes so
um this is uh five hundred thousand
dollars a year for New Hampshire public
television and as I understand it that
was removed from the budget 12 years ago
um and now it's coming back but in my
mind
you know the public doesn't need
um
we don't need to take funds from the
public to create television I mean if
there's anything we have plenty of it's
videos and television so
um
I just think this is an inappropriate
expenditure
okay I'll we'll take this under
advisement only because it's after 12
and we are lacking a number of our
members representative Sweeney and
Hewitt are not here so before we took a
vote on it I'd like to because it's a
significant change I guess if you will
or ask rather so we can take this up
from perhaps on Monday but thanks for
providing Us in advance
all right uh is there are there any
other questions for the commissioner or
are we okay with it
budget is presented with the obviously
recognizing we do have an amendment
which could adjust your budget the 500
000 a year for the public television
seeing no I guess we're okay with the
budget
okay Mr Hoffman is there something else
would that include the uh 150 000 for
Utilities in the doit position thanks
for reminding us of that yes it would I
think we kind of but thanks for
reminding us
so um May I just ask um for process
purposes so you'll say you'll take up
the amendment on Monday
would you like somebody from our agency
there to answer questions yeah we have
uh General discussion of the budget
starting Monday again trying to get to
the final stage okay and uh what I'll do
is I'll just schedule it for 9 30. so
you have a specific time wonderful uh
just before the vote on the retirement
well we have two retirement bills at 9
30. I just scheduled it for 9 30 on
Monday morning all right
um
are they both scheduled for 9 30. you
know yes okay
those may take some significant time so
we'll
we'll get you in at 9 30 along with
those perfect so we'll get we'll take
care of that first and then we'll move
to our other business thank you okay
all right we're adjourned until one
o'clock we have um oplc review at one we
have the chair of the
Edna committee representative Carol
McGuire and several other reps I guess
that are coming to to speak to us about
so because we have so many folks here
foreign
the discussion on oplc uh several weeks
ago I asked the
Edna committee that's chaired by
representative Carol Maguire
if she could take a look at these
sections that were proposed to change or
run their own schedule out or whatever
the case may be
I think they're like 257
sections or 54 sections but anyway
um representative McGuire you're welcome
to tell us what you found or what you're
suggesting all right thank you the this
is five amendments for your
consideration
the first one I
I in the entire committee hopes that you
will adopt because
it's
essentially it's the house position
it starts by deleting sections 285 and
286 which are Pages 90 to 102 and that's
the whole real
statutory recodification of the oplc
organization
the reason to delete it is that we
included that in House Bill 655 which
we all passed yesterday on consent
and it has somewhat expanded language in
some areas where the DNA committee
thought it needed it a disciplinary
investigations and so forth
so it is
in hopes of that you and you and I would
not have to try and keep these two
sections in sync that we want you to
take it out of house bill to
um
you can continue okay fine thanks uh on
page 110
uh section
310 replaced secretary of state with the
executive director incorrectly
I did not we want to replace the
secretary of state with the executive
director and in section 311 we do not
want to replace the secretary of state
with executive director it looks like
the
um that fell through the cracks this is
relative to the transfer of the
auctioneers board
and section 310 is the responsibilities
of the Secretary of State toward the
board which are now being transferred to
oplc and section 311 is the business
title restrictions and that is still the
Secretary of State's responsibility I
believe he pointed that out to uh to
section 315 I forget which board that is
it's a minor edit the the section lists
the members of the board but that
doesn't change
the original number of members from
seven to five even though the five
members are specifically listed further
on in the paragraph that's a an easy one
on
sections 421 and 427 which is the
massage
therapy section
the board is combined with the boards of
Asian Bodywork Reiki and um
I forget what else
um
which is mine but it also incorporates a
establishment license that the house
killed when we killed house bill 341. so
the edits on those sections merely
remove the reference to establishments
so that's the house position
um
on Section 484 it calls for two Hospital
pharmacists on the pharmacy board
upon consideration that's a typo it
the other two points are that first of
all
if we're going to repeal any licenses
Edna strongly believes the fees should
be re refunded
and the oplc agrees and they ask that it
be simply refunded and not prorated
because it's simpler for them to just
send out the checks that way
we didn't have any problem with that
and then
we want to change the effective date
from
July 1st to September
because with Theory structuring these
boards you're going to have to have the
governor and Council approving a whole
lot of new appointees and
we think a little more time is
appropriate
and that's that's that amendment of 2023
1007.
any questions
representative evil so just so unclear
this is a committee Amendment
I got my name on it it all of the points
that I mentioned were specifically
discussed with the committee and it is
the committee consensus that they need
to be included in house build need to be
okay
are there any other questions on at
from the division
any
there is a hand up of
recognize the gentleman or gentle woman
I can't tell in the back
oh oh okay
yeah thanks
yeah
so seeing no questions on that the
division won't make a decision on any of
this until Monday give it an opportunity
of the members to take a look at it over
the weekend
all right that's fine the Second
Amendment the lead sections 443 444 and
445 which are the consolidation of the
licensed Alcohol and Other Drug
counselors into the board of mental
health practice
that is a section that we took out of
house bill 655 because we had
some concerns about it those concerns
remain we don't think the consolidation
uh
has been fully vetted and we'd like to
pull it out of house bill too and let
Edna work on it
um
there's no money involved so it
yes representative camberells thank you
Mr chair uh and thank you representative
McGuire taking the question
um I see that it says delete sections
443 to 445 yes 443 is the deletes the
board of licensed alcohol and drug
counselors 444 deletes the board of
psychology in 445 rewrites the board of
mental health practice to include these
other
but it says Pages 160 through 181. it's
a
fact but the uh um 443 444 and 445 are
all on page 160. they start 440 section
445 finishes on page 181 got you thank
and I will say that we have a regulatory
bill that we have retained with the
expectation that we would cons we would
include any
the division on this
seeing none but I guess you could move
along to amendment number three well
three and four ought to be considered
together
um
the nursing assist the licensed nursing
assistant LNA is proposed in House Bill
2 to
uh
not require a license just the federal
certification
this caused a lot of consternation and
Edna and various people that talk to us
because the scope of practice for a
licensed nursing assistant is
significantly broader than the scope of
practice for the certified federally
certified nursing assistant
there's also questions of supervision a
LNA is responsible for their own
continuing education
and you know making sure they get it
whereas a nursing assistant has no
requirements and any uh continuing
education is the responsibility of the
employer
also the nursing assistant is working
under the supervision and under the
license of a registered nurse or a
licensed practical nurse whatever level
of licensed
health care worker and those professions
have said that they don't want to buy
don't want to have that responsibility
so
again this may be the right thing to do
but we're Edna was
overwhelmingly convinced that it hadn't
been thought through so we'd like to
pull that
Amendment four just takes all the
changes of the nursing board out of stat
out of house bill to
Amendment Three
um
changes some of the board sections to
decrease the number of board members as
the governor wished
and
to keep the language of a nursing
assistant in statute
um
that was my first approach on how to
deal with this but when I went back I
thought that it might make more sense
just to delete those two those few
sections
the Board of Nursing is one of our
largest boards
they have there's something like 30 000
nurses
so we're more
uh it makes more sense to have a larger
so it's those are for your consideration
you can do it either way you think we
just don't think we ought to re just
representative Deanne McGuire and thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
McGuire
um so are you saying that Amendment
Three is additions
in some sense because you said Amendment
four you you took away all changes to
nursing yes but three has specific
adding back certain changes to nursing
is that the idea section three makes
changes to the
part of House Bill 2 that deals with the
Board of Nursing and the licensees of
the Board of Nursing
uh
the two are you can either pick one or
the other they're two different
approaches to how to handle it I'm
willing to let you guys figure it out
so you're saying we can't pass three and
four it's just three or just four is
that correct they are they are
alternatives not compliments thank you
very much
representative evil yeah I
I've clarified this but one suggests
changes if we decide to leave 460
6 and 67 in but the other option is just
to get rid of 46 through 42 and let you
guys work on it some more
yes representative Dan McGuire does does
Amendment Three de-license lnas
yes
it talks about instead of creating a new
title nursing Aid it talks about a
nursing assistant it doesn't specify the
license
but it um
it leaves the definition of a nursing
your other question representative
Damocles
yeah
thinking on it I would recommend you
take the second choice because that's a
little cleaner but
I would be so inclined
well yeah the the first was how I first
looked at it and then after
discussing it and with some other people
and thinking about it I think it'd be
simpler just to not change the board of
is there any more discussion on uh
Amendment Three or Amendment four from
I don't see any
okay so a question for the chair of Edna
the suggestion of amendment three and o4
was that from the committee did there
was there no no
recommendation from the committee was
that we needed to look at the
um
the LNA license we didn't think just
deleting it was
uh the right way to go at this point in
time and it was actually talking
reading a few of the many emails I got
on the subject talking to the nursing
home administrator from Merrimack County
and talking to your staff
I decided it would be simpler just to do
do Amendment for but I wanted to offer
you the choice
oh thanks
representable
so as we decide whether we're going to
delete these sections from hb2 what
would be next in the process you would
just take on the the review of these
things and then ultimately introduce
another bill or just as I said in your
mind we have a retained bill on
regulation
Professional Regulation that we can use
to amend it to include the
the board of board of Mental Health
recodification because that was
we were expecting to use it for
um
any changes to the board of Mental
Health
because we they were several issues that
we hadn't resolved that we took out of
and so we that's the plan we could also
deal with the nurses in the same bill or
submit another bill for next year
now you say whatever makes sense what
um
the board of mental health we have to
talk about because we there are a number
of issues that uh
that need to be be considered before we
make any make those changes
um the lnas I'm
I'm leaning toward just saying don't
leave them alone don't bother them but
that's
all right representative Dion McGuire
yeah I was just going to say so board so
amendment number two throws the board of
mental health back at the Edna committee
for their decision right and amendment
number four essentially does the same
thing for the nursing area right and
amendment number one deals with things
all right should we go to number five
yes uh moving on to number
are there any uh licenses that you
the
these amendments are essentially the
consensus of the Edna committee we we
looked at this this section of House
Bill 2 and did triage and we took what
we consider were the important issues
that we wanted
uh you'd either
do or not do as the case may be
um
there were moving on to amendment number
five there were the Foresters Landscape
Architects and natural scientists
and we were convinced those licenses
should not be repealed at this time
because
primarily there are so many places in
our laws our rules and town laws and
rules that required uh
a natural scientists to stamp this or
seal this or sign for it and we didn't
believe that
um
we felt that if you're going to delete
the license you have to address those
issues there are some national
certifications but they're not as
standard as some people would like to
believe
and I don't believe the Foresters really
have National certification
so we think that
the the license is necessary until a
little more groundwork's been done on
all the places that call for these
licenses
thank you I agree there are a lot of
these things in in town ordinances and
so on that that refer to these jobs and
yeah the Wetland scientists in
particular are all over everything land
use boards sewers septic systems so
and
I didn't want to go through and try and
find those all those references
so amendment five repeals the sections
repealing Foresters Landscape Architects
and natural scientists and adds in a
simplified board combining for all three
professions
it probably won't make them happy but it
does cover the details the requirements
for the license are the same as in
current statute
and the exemptions are
combined and clearer so that it's
obvious that
any of these licenses are not needed
just to work in the profession you need
it to be the lead of an organization
the same way that the Professional
Engineers license is needed by the lead
of the organization and not necessarily
every engineer who works
under that person I mean I I was an
engineer and I knew some people that
went to get a professional engineer's
license but that is primarily for people
who want to be in business for
themselves
it's not for uh
the thousands of Engineers working for
the GE at Eric and the aircraft business
so and the examinations make it clear
that the employees don't need to be
licensed government officials don't need
to be licensed people don't need to be
um
there's no double licensing required if
you're a Forester
you can deal or a soil scientist you can
deal with things that are normally
considered landscape architecture or
professional engineering as long as it's
in your scope of practice you don't need
a double license
and then there's some specific
exemptions but for the most part it's as
I said for the lead person and in an
organization or somebody working for
themselves
and that was the intent
uh I just was told somebody in the
audience had their hand raised yes
they're good representative from
Manchester we like to comment take the
mic so everyone can hear you well I I
just I have one only one other thing to
say these recommendations were were
essentially the consensus of Edna that
they had to be addressed
various other members have various other
issues and there's I think four of them
behind behind me bringing them to your
attention uh
but you'll
these are as I said the consensus of the
committee and we hope you hope you will
support them
so I I did have a question so we heard
from a court reporter or maybe several
them and going through some of these
changes I noticed like real estate
appraisers that they would that would be
repealed and no the real estate
appraisers got moved
okay they are they are they are
they're moving from the dra to oplc it
was started last year when we created a
specific board versus assessor
certification
and this completes the the
reorganization the licenses and training
yeah there are four boards that that are
relocated the the assessors the
Auctioneers
uh
interpreters for the Deaf
that comes from education and the
auctioneers board is from the Secretary
of State
but that though that language other than
that one little slip up I saw looked
looked reasonable and it's a they didn't
need any addition
now was there any discussion with the
commissioner commissioner's step as far
as moving
the appraisers I I didn't look up these
different statues but I know that anyone
we talked with dra last year when we uh
were dealing with the appraisers board I
know the secretary of state is would be
delighted to get rid of some of these
boards oh with boxing and wrestling
um they're they're not really a part of
his organization so he's he thinks it
should be there we didn't talk to
education about the interpreters for the
deaf but uh Theo PLC has no problem with
it no I'm just curious about dra if you
if someone spoke to the commissioner
about moving
they had members of their organization
that is
that our assessors and they worked with
the assessing Standards Board the
licensing of the actual assessors was
not something they really cared a whole
lot about
at least that was the impression I got
so when your committee reviewed all
these I assume you went down through
each section and the company said this
is a good thing or a bad thing or did
you no we started with uh those of us
who had poured over House Bill 2 in our
free time and looked and brought up the
issues we thought were important
the court reporters were mentioned and
one member is concerned about the light
deleting the license but the rest of the
committee did was not convinced to go
along
one member was concerned about
consolidating the podiatrists into the
Board of Medicine
but the rest of the committee didn't
think that was a big deal
a couple of us went through this list
and looked for problems and these are
the ones that the committee agreed
needed to be dealt with there are I
wouldn't
venture to say that there are no
problems with any of the other parts but
there's certainly
uh not having risen to the level of
these
okay are there any further questions for
the chair of the Edna committee
representative EPO so that was exactly
the question I was going to ask you that
doesn't necessarily mean that Edna has
blessed all the other parts that you
have not commented on but these were the
things that you were particularly
concerned about as a committee exactly
okay and then I just have one on the on
the Foresters Landscape Architects so
this is
are you saying each of them now have
their own board and the recommendation
of e-dna is to combine them under one
the
the amendment combines them into one
board
there aren't a lot of soil scientists I
think there's 30 there's a couple of
hundred Wetland scientists there's not a
lot of people in in and there's a
hundred
150 or so Landscape Architects they're
they're not very large
and so combining them since they worked
together made made some sense and in
view of the fact that the governor had
deleted
recommended deleting the license and the
board
um
you we thought we thought that combining
the boards made sense
it's
you could also
interpret it to say we should just
delete the three sections that repeal
all those boards and leave them as is
that that's your choice okay
okay thank you
so Madam chair did you have any
discussion about the number of public
appointees that were eliminated there
were a number of boards and public
members
a number of them were reduced those that
is because those were
regulatory boards converted to advisory
boards
and that was particular for the smaller
professions or the ones that have had
the most difficulty filling their board
or maintaining a quorum
so that the administration and the
rulemaking is directed to the office of
professional licensure and The Advisory
Board provides the technical backup to
make sure that the
um
concerns of the light of the profession
are addressed properly
and a public member is much less vital
thank you representative Dan McGuire
thank you so number one please stick
around
because I'm sure other questions will
come up or things but
um just in general I think would you
agree that what we've discovered is for
some of these very small boards
um
like for example The Midwives or
something there's there's two or three
dozen of them in the whole state and and
therefore everybody knows everybody and
it's harder for them to discipline each
other
Etc and that's part of the reason that
they're doing some moving some to oplc
and making them advisory
um that's part of it last year we in
Senate Bill 330 we dealt with converting
a significant number of boards from
regulatory to advisory
partly for that
and The Midwives were considered but
uh were not did not actually become
advisory but like you say it's uh
there's a Kate there's a problem with
midwives so they can get a great many
complaints and there are so few of them
in the state that it's very difficult to
get a
uh unbiased
um
judges that were
when there is a complaint yeah and and a
related thing is that we discovered that
quite a few boards
almost everyone licensed is actually
doesn't live in New Hampshire so for
example the Landscape Architects they
have say 200 licensees but 42 live in
New Hampshire and the other 150 are from
elsewhere and so therefore creating a
board of new hampshire-based is a little
tougher right so uh it depends there I
believe the Foresters Landscape
Architects and natural scientists were
considered for
the license were considered for a
removal in part because there were so
few complaints
that the board didn't need to spend a
lot of time and effort disciplining them
because they were very few issues with
so you raised the issue of discipline
now a number of these boards had an
advisory role as far as disciplinary
action and I see that there's sections
where the executive director has that
complete Authority for Discipline Do you
think that could be problematic if we
didn't have a good director like we
guess we have now or
um I don't believe the director is going
to be sitting as a judge on these cases
the structure is that there will be a
hearings officer there will be a
investigator who is knowledgeable about
the profession that's that's being
investigated and that the here there
will be hearings officers that can and
judge
the cases on their Merit
there were sections that that may not
hold quite true
why which ones are you I'm looking at um
on page 108 where it says
it's crossed out board and it says the
executive director May disa or take
disciplinary action in any one or more
of the following ways
uh public or private reprimand by
suspension license verification
um yes that's the the under the the
profession the
um
the issues about how that is done are
covered under the under house bill 655
the section we're taking out of house
bill two there are how the investigation
is to be done and how the hearings are
to be uh
representative McGuire thank you so I
would just comment I mean
often in law it's the commissioner does
something but really it's somebody who
works for the commissioner who ends up
doing that thing and I think this is
similar right this would be the hearing
officer who's actually making the
decision and disciplining the the case
if you look on line 25 it's it says
disciplinary action under this paragraph
may be ordered by the board after a
hearing well the board's been removed it
that's what my concern is that I think
it's putting a lot of Authority in one
individual whether he or she but
so that particular line looks like a
technical music yeah it looks like line
24.
um
that does look like an executive
director so again that kind of language
concerns me because you're putting an
awful lot of authority and if someone
wanted to appeal the decision I don't
know if that's quite clear maybe this
individual can set fines of up to two
thousand dollars
so those are the things that just
skimming through this earlier caught my
attention I made little notes but I
believe that
um
those
disciplinary actions are typical of
Licensing boards that's which one is
this
acupuncture yeah okay well again it was
it's a board but not one individual it's
a board of what a five or two or three
versus one individual
not just a concern I had Madam chair
um if you're if it's a criminal case
you're going to have one judge unless
you happen to have a jury in in many
cases the the board is more of the jury
all right well I guess we can talk about
that further about that than I do I'm
afraid I'm not at all familiar with book
with courts cases
well I've sat on review boards before
and just it's usually like a board of
several individuals a little Fair
process than just one individual that's
not a judge that's appointed by
governor and executive Council but are
there further questions well thanks
representative grassy any comments yet
representative cambrell's
represent evil yes I had I had two we've
gotten
um conflicting testimony on the
acupuncture issue and I didn't know if
you guys had talked about that
uh we heard testimony from two different
groups one of whom loves the changes and
one of them hates them
and our usual practice in that case is
to
throw throw it throw the baby out with
the bath water and say we're not gonna
not gonna make a decision until you guys
can figure out what your what the
I mean is it somewhat it's a
professional dispute and some of it is a
complaint about the personalities
and that those are always very difficult
to enroute
more I know a couple of people have been
interested in the Hawker and Peddler
license did you have a feeling on that
uh yes we passed that last year
in the house the repeal of that license
it's the Secretary of State at that time
assured us that first of all they have
never rejected anyone's license because
of a criminal
criminal background check they do the
check and then they give them the
license and they have never rejected
anyone for any reason related to the
background check and no one in
decades at least has ever claimed the
bond that is required to be posted so
the Edna was convinced that this license
really didn't do a whole lot except
hassle the people who wanted
to do
um
hope to be Hawkers or Peddlers there are
municipal licenses that are
in many cases much more rigorous
so I guess uh we're all set all right
thank you thanks Madam chair good job
the representative from Manchester did I
see her
hand up a little while ago
you know this state your name for the
my name is Jane bolier a representative
uh in from Manchester District 19. I
serve on Commerce
this year next year I do have and I'm
not quite sure if I should be addressing
this committee or another committee but
um
eight so 655 is a bill
that was
um introduced
as a section of hb2 to be
pulled out
to be discussed
and my question is is um
I'm I'm a 50-year um
cosmetologist and it looks like
the license for cosmetologist is going
to be repealed
I think well if I could 655 was a
standalone bill and I guess some of the
sections have wandered into house bill
too but again it's an awful lot of
Professional Regulation the study
committee this summer
we then when we found that it was
we went to Edna we worked on it
and as I said we beefed up some sections
that needed some work
and then the
um
then we'd noticed it in House Bill 2 and
said let's not try and keep two two of
them together
none of them affect the cosmetologist's
license except
in-house Bill 2 it deletes the booth
license
none of the others all of the
requirements for a cosmetologist an
esthetician a barber a manicurist are
the same it's only the additional Booth
license
in addition to the uh
a shop license could you tell us what
you said a booth license well I I'm just
curious I guess never been to it in many
uh Beauty parlors for sure I don't know
about Barbers but probably the owner of
the facility has a license as a as a
shop and as an individual
licensed person and the people who are
actually working at the chairs doing the
work may be employees and
or they may be independent contractors
the
in either case the owner of the shop is
responsible for the overall operation of
the shop and the individuals doing the
work are required to be licensed for the
work they're doing
and that none of that changes they just
took the uh the booth license out
because it's confusing because if you
look online
um it does there's 34 licenses that
they're looking to repeal is that not
correct right now and the booth license
is the only one that falls under the
Board of Cosmetology and
um
Natural Science scientists soil
scientists Wetland scientist are you
grouping those together
the soil scientists and Wetland
scientists are currently grouped
together as natural scientists
so you're not eliminating any of these
licenses we're recommending to finance
that they
repeal that they pull out that license
deletion
okay
so how many of the 34 that are listed
are going to be repealed
because if you look online it still
looks like all of these are going to be
repealed you won't see any changes to
House Bill 2 until after it's been
changed by finance and by the house so
I'm sorry
because there's so many changes here and
we've been inundated but with folks with
concerns that would like a lot of things
to say and some there's been some
support for some of the things that have
been suggested within House Bill too but
we as Finance right division one right
we have to make a recommendation whether
we accept what chairman McGuire has
advocated for or do we throw the whole
thing out or do we make some changes
ourselves but traditionally when
something comes to us it has policy
major policy change like this we send it
to the policy committee
for their review and comment so once we
absorb all of this information we're
getting today and we will make a
recommendation to the full finance
committee in a week
so
so it's it will be ultimately our
decision but we're looking for
recommendations from e-dna right because
I mean the reason why I'm here is it's
going to affect
thousands of people in businesses and
I don't think there's been enough
opportunity for the general public or
residents in the state to really
understand
what this is all about I mean how is
this going to affect them their business
their child the college you know I
I don't know
no you raised some very valid points and
that was our concern when we first got
it because it contains like I mentioned
earlier hundreds of changes which
weren't in my just speaking for myself
weren't properly aired in the
traditional way before a policy
committee right and it's oftentimes
you'll see this in a Governor's budget
with a Visa policy suggested changes but
there's never been anything to this
magnitude because in my right terms here
yeah and I I've never seen it either
so I think representative McGuire may
have a question for you well I I to
answer your question which I don't think
I heard yet
um from the original list of 34 I think
it was yes
like seven six or seven
if you if we pass rep representative
Carol McGuire's suggestions six or seven
would not be eliminated correct so that
leaves like 28 or something like that
there are of those 28 I think 12 of them
are temporary licenses and so and most
of the others are things like the
Hawkers and Peddlers
um
that was repealed
oh yes so it's back here in the house
built too okay
um the athlete agents of which there are
three or four or five or something like
that
um and a handful and if you know I'm
talking about the cosmetology license
Barbarian cosmetology and Aesthetics so
there's not again it's only the booth
license
not the cosmetology not the barber not
the
all that's here is the booth license so
the separate license for the chair
yes that's somebody I understand yeah
yeah so that's it that's the only one
so so the cosmetology license so the
schools the cosmetology schools all that
stuff is the same no change
yes yeah
go ahead Jackie yeah representative
groda
I think I believe representative groder
my name is Jackie groda I am a member of
Edna and I've been a member of the Edna
committee for all three terms that I've
been in the house
I also sit on gel car
I want to assure
um
representative build here that
um cosmetology licenses barbering
cosmetology and estheticians have not
deleted repealed it's only the chair of
someone in a cosmetology who who is in a
salon
but I really would like to it this is I
would like to approach the committee and
talk with you about a few things if it's
okay I hadn't okay
so I'm in looking at representative
McGuire's
um amendments I think it's important
that I confirm with you
my understanding of the discussions that
we had because
um I said I would I chaired the
subcommittee on House Bill 655 we had
two subcommittee meetings
I also participated last Friday in the
work session that the committee had on
House Bill 655.
655 is a massive bill
and even for those on Edna it is a large
undertaking
knowing that we do this all the time
so I want to agree with the Amendments
that representative McGuire
um
I'm concerned about and also
the amendment
in number two the board of Mental Health
and I want to caution you on the merging
of boards
because the board of psychology was
separated from the Mental Health Board
some time ago and now we're merging it
back and this is where the question is
and why we want to pull it out because
there was a considerable amount of time
spent when these boards were not were
separate
but and so I agree with her that we want
to pull out that section we recommend
that you pull out that section of House
built 2.
now there was a very clear
message because we voted
and one of the vote one of the part of
our vote was to re to remove the LNA
repeal from house bill 2. there's no
question about that vote
we don't believe that lnas should
licenses should be repealed
we also agreed that we thought
forrester's landsaker Architects soil
scientists Wetland scientists should be
those repeals should be removed
we did not agree on the merging of them
in a board
we only discussed representative Maguire
said she was working on something mind
you we've never seen this until today
but we did not agree to merge it in any
specific board we talked about putting
it together in a technical board but
that was something up for discussion
we kept House Bill 518 as a retained
bill so that any non-germaine amendment
that we made in relationship to House
I do want to also make some statements
about the repealing of additional
now mind you
this takes some time to research because
there are so many regulations that
involve oplc
but I want to pick out two right now
last year because of the activity on
some of the boards we agreed to change
the board of Medical Imaging and
radiation therapy to an Advisory Board
that was done through house bill 1018.
today the gel the rules for the this
Advisory Board were on gel Carr's agenda
under the consent calendar
the governor signed that bill
in on July of 2022.
and here we are today repealing the
licenses for that profession
last we also did the same thing with the
board of court reporters we also changed
them to an Advisory Board underneath
House Bill 1182 that was signed in May
of 2022.
the rules for this the rules were
approved today in Jill Carr on a consent
calendar and again A year later less
than a year later here we are repealing
the licensing for this profession
so in testimony one of the professions
in both the testimony on House Bill 655
and House Bill 2 the comments from the
professionals who were being converted
to The Advisory boards saying that this
was just a transition to eventually
repealing of their licenses
now that may be or that may not be but I
can assure you that the house does not
want to lose the trust of the people who
send us here with our responsibilities
we've seen this with the retirement
system and I really would caution you
um
now
merging of the boards
merging the Board of Medicine with the
medical review subcommittee and the
board of Podiatry
the Board of Medicine and the medical
review board are separated for specific
reasons the medical review board is the
investigating arm of medical complaints
while adjudication is done by the Board
of Medicine
it's important that these elements
remain separate
and in hb2 they're merged
also Podiatry is very much against this
merger
the the resistance
but when there's this much resistance to
something it's usually something that's
worth a discussion
and I guess what I'm saying to you is
that there's so many components of House
Bill 2 that are similar to this let's
just look at the disciplinary action
alone it helps Bill 655 the subcommittee
hearing a significant portion of it was
about the resistance of eliminating this
disciplinary actions of the board
maybe that there's another way of doing
this in a less drastic way so that and
I'm not saying that oplc is
an agency that can't manage this
I have respect for the people of oplc
however
this is not something that I think
should be this is these are policy
um so what I share with you in an
organized but different manner than
house bill 2.
is an overview of perhaps the unintended
consequences that could result
and I recommend a targeted and
thoughtful approach to this legislation
that takes more time than we have if we
want to do it correctly
very helpful thanks for your comments
and recommendations
um
representative evil I believe has a
question right so I think I I really
appreciate your specific comments but
overall
um I just want to reiterate what I
believe I'm hearing in your expertise on
Edna and reviewing this you basically
think this is too much too fast and you
think all of it should have a lot more
analysis
well I'm not gonna you know argue over
Peddlers and Hawkers right but there are
many components about this that should
I just have one one question at some
point could you give us the bill that
the house the bill number of the uh that
the house passed on Hawkers and Peddlers
sure okay
and I'll be glad to send to you my notes
we'd appreciate that so I raised a
question earlier with the chairman about
the disciplinary Factor
could you comment on that does it in my
way off base that you have one
individual overseeing disciplinary
action or
well I don't think it would be one
individual I think it would be
um and this is the part where I'm not I
don't know what the system would be
so this is the kind of discussion that
we would have to have
thanks
um I just the director one I see or he
and I'm happy to do an overview of
what's in House Bill 2 if you would
think that would be helpful but specific
to the disciplinary issues
right now the way it works is that for
boards that are independent regulatory
bodies which are the large majority of
our boards the boards that aren't
advisory boards
all of them use the hearings officer and
the hearings officer helps facilitate
the hearing
and
assists with ruling on evidentiary
motions
but the issue is that it is truly the
board that has the authority to rule on
evidential emotions and make findings or
I'm sorry rulings of law
boards by and large are not attorneys
and they're not necessarily qualified to
be making legal decisions on evidentiary
matters and so a lot of those boards all
of the boards have essentially delegated
that to the hearings officer and the
boards make the findings of fact for
example
um the facts alleged in a professional
misconduct case are that the nurse
diverted fentanyl the board will make
the finding that the nurse did divert
Fentanyl and the hearings officer will
will draw the legal conclusion that the
diversion of fentanyl is professional
misconduct based both on the finding
effect by the Board of Nursing and the
expert testimony that was provided in
conjunction with the expertise of the
board members with respect to the
Advisory Board the process works the
same way except technically the
authority Rises up to the executive
director the hearings officer presides
over the hearing The Advisory Board
provides a consultation the reason why
this is helpful in our perspective is
particularly when you get to those
smaller boards and the boards have full
control over disciplinary matters we
have observed issues where people know
everybody everybody knows everybody and
they may choose not to discipline
somebody because they like the person
um and that obviously uh is not a
legitimate legal conclusion so
um from our perspective and this is what
655 recommended that uh the person who's
qualified usually in a trained attorney
makes rulings of law and the board who
are experts makes findings in fact and
the analysis is conducted based on based
on that so we already have that
framework representative
um but if you don't mind I'd be happy to
go through an overview of postable too
well just backing up to the language I
referenced before sure it makes it very
clear that board has been strickened in
a number of spots and it says the
executive director makes those decisions
and you just kept referring to the board
the board the board but throughout this
document it says the executive director
and board is crossed out I think you're
probably referring to the boards that
are being proposed to be converted to
Advisory Board and we have six or seven
of those six now and the language is
nearly identical and it's already
functioning in that capacity
so you're obvious to be aware of the
concerns that these changes since
there's some support we heard from the
Secretary of State's office there are
some smaller agencies that he'd be happy
to move to your
licensure board
but why didn't this go through the
normal process of a review by the policy
committee well I think I'm sorry it's
such a major change you know obviously
um again some things are probably good
and some things are not but
I think and again just speaking for
myself I think it's a little unfair to
put something like this before
Finance with such little time
to really review it thoroughly because I
can speak for this division over the
years we try to be very thorough in
whatever decisions we make we try to you
know be thoughtful and listen to both
sides but this gives us so such a little
time to really review these thoroughly
um so can you speak to that why this
wasn't presented maybe to the Edna
committee
in a bill last year because obviously
these things didn't happen overnight
somebody's been thinking about this
well to be clear this is an oplc's bill
but uh this is a bill in House Bill 2
that proposes significant structural
changes within an agency and we've seen
that time and time and again in House
Bill 2 in fact in 2015 and that Budget
Trailer that's how oplc was created so
it is pretty commonplace for the
governor to propose major structural
changes within an executive branch
agency last year I think it was
Department of energy
obviously I referenced hoplc
um you know so I think you know I can't
speak to you know the governor's
decision and any respect but that this
is how the process works when there are
proposals within House Bill 2 it goes to
finance
and I think it's pretty consistent with
what we've seen in the past regarding
structural changes for agencies and and
that is true we actually saw the split
up of dread several years ago but it
wasn't quite as extensive at this and it
wasn't a huge policy shift that affected
perhaps tens of thousands of people at
once that's that's what I was getting to
because obviously again not to debate
you about this but
it appears to me that you must have had
some input to the governor's requests
because these are all affecting your
agency it certainly we're consulted as I
believe most agencies are when there are
anticipated to be major structural
changes but I think we're putting the
car before the horse here because what I
think would make sense and I don't want
to disagree with you
um representative there are significant
structural changes that are proposed but
we haven't had an overall overview of
what those changes are and rather than
pick and choose which portions that we'd
like to discuss it may make sense for me
to go through House Bill 2 and actually
explain what is within the bill and and
to the extent that you have questions
I'd be happy to answer those yeah if you
have a handout that would be great I
well um
Mr Hoffman is handing out this uh he had
a representative Schmidt from Dover I
believe would like to ask a question or
you want to take my seat please today
thank you Mr chairman for the record
representative Peter Schmidt represent
Dover Ward one and I've been on the Edna
committee now this is my 17th year 20th
year in the house
um and uh I'm really pleased to have the
opportunity to work with you because
several members of the committee
yourself included have asked some very
penetrating questions which I very much
agree with and I'd like to address but
I'd like to begin by saying that uh the
director Courtney and I have worked
together since she has taken over as the
executive director and I'm very
supportive of the the efforts that she's
engaged in to try to shape oplc into a
much more functional organization which
I think it has not been since its
Inception uh for reasons I won't get
into but but the thing is that her skill
as a trained lawyer but also has
management background has been very
felicitous in terms of getting at some
of these problems which
have a long it took a long time to put
all this stuff together and unwinding it
in a very very short period of time
too little time in my judgment is is
very risky
that in many of the steps that director
Courtney has initiated I think
show promise to to bring about a better
situation because even though it hasn't
been referenced very much in this
hearing one of the problems with with
some of the smaller boards especially is
the problem of getting a quorum together
and many of these boards do not meet
monthly some of the smaller ones only
meet every couple of months so a lot of
the processed things that that oplc can
do on a on a very quick basis because
they're there
five days a week
they have people who are trained
attorneys trained administrators
and the other things that go into a
competent administrative structure
um and they should be doing those things
and they are doing those things ever
more and they've been working together
with Edna and the leadership both on the
Democratic and Republican side in Edna
has been watching this situation with
growing concern because we have been and
those of you who've been here for a
while has seen and the director will
affirm this
um that in many cases the um
uh the
the statute uh needs amending
so there's something she just can't do
on her own for all the planning that's
involved she can't actually do some of
the things without working with us and
we have been amending the statutes for
some time now
taking out commissioner or board or
whatever and put in an executive
director
that is
fortuitous in some respects but it's
also risky right it's kind of like when
you're on that tightrope
when you're pressing down on the Rope
you're safe You Wobble and you're down
on the ground maybe a long way down on
the ground so the thing is that we
started a couple years ago with some of
the very very small boys like Midwifery
which was referenced earlier right
because they were having a hard time
with quorum and then the whole thing
gets squishy so we had a thing which a
bill that was going to put the executive
director into Authority and make the
board advisory
but this concept is not well understood
and it's very scary to these boards they
think that they're going to get
de-licensed and deregulated and they're
going to get done away with that's not
my purpose I can tell you when it's not
edina's purpose and I deeply believe
that it's not director Courtney's
purpose either it's to try to create a
structure that works better than what we
have now at least for smaller boards for
sure the bigger boards I think are in a
much better situation generally
so the thing is that
with regard to House Bill 2 and some of
the questions that you asked earlier as
I said were very perceptive and I'd like
to try to answer some of them so the
thing is that
there there's some good ideas in
I've been using the
press release That You released back on
the 22nd of February I think as kind of
a working diagram right some of the
principles in unseated on page one I
very much agree with but when it comes
to instituting them in the repeal or
merging a boards or repealing of
professions and occupations then it's
kind of surgery with a MedEx
some of these professions and
occupations absolutely do not
deserve to be repealed we've already
mentioned soil scientists Foresters and
so forth and I think that they have
already been kind of pulled out
but let's take court reporters
people think well they're not in the
courts anymore it's a dying profession
it's not a dying profession it's still a
very Dynamic profession that's very much
used in depositions and I know some of
these court reporters and they say
they're still making a very good living
and they're very important they're by
virtue of their license they're able to
swear people in
they're able to act as notaries and they
also have the skill and of course those
of us who serve on gel car and the
director's there on a regular basis we
have a court reporter
because we need a viable vital accurate
record
can't get that with a tape recorder when
somebody coughs or slams a door or
something like that and the transcript
comes back when it's a tape recorder
that transcripts some comes back and it
says
inaudible
inaudible the court reporter when that
happens they say judge
I didn't get that can we have that
remark or that statement repeated so now
you get a transcript that's worth
something it's a viable record so court
reporters are still very important even
though there are not very many of them
left
but you know there's only one Wizard of
Oz too I mean it depends on there's only
there was only one Vladimir Horowitz too
but he did play the piano pretty well so
the thing is
this took a long time to put together
and every one of these licensed
professions was the result of a
conscious individual decision on the
part of the legislature sometimes a
hundred years ago
and to unwind all of that in the time
that you have and we had
in my judgment is completely premature
and unworkable
for all the idea that it's there's some
of these some nuggets of good
information and perhaps some of these
boards can be put together in a
different way and the director's working
on this and we're working on it whether
an Edna
so I think your question earlier about
um why wasn't this started some time ago
I can't answer that question and I wish
it had been because that's what we
stopped one of the Omnibus bills a
couple of years ago because it was going
to give the executive director's
position
a lot more Authority and we said we
don't want that until we can see how
that's going to be exercised because
we didn't have a complete handle on how
that was going to be done and it very
much depends on having a good executive
director but also a concept that really
works and I think the idea of having the
administrative side in its entirety
be in the hands of
opoc but the substance of the
professions and the occupations and
their governance to be done by the
people who are the practitioners of that
profession and that that occupation
and it takes just like it takes two legs
to walk or run
maybe you got one real good leg but if
you've got one real bad leg
maybe you can hop like heck but you
can't run or walk
and so it takes that teamwork between
director Courtney and her increasingly
competent and experienced staff but it
also takes the expertise of the board
members and the public members they
shouldn't be dismissed
to handle the
the real mechanics the inner workings of
the professions be it medicine law or
forestry for that matter so I think I
think we are we are need DNA we're
deeply committed
to uh to doing this in conjunction with
the efforts of the executive director
here but I think and it's it's in its
totality that this concept of putting
this in the trailer bill is premature
and unworkable
so I'll be happy to answer any questions
you may have thank you representative
are there any questions for
Representatives
yeah this is the thank you Mr chairman
this is the first time I've sat on this
side of the table at the inside of the
other side that's true versus vice versa
so
um let's talk about court reporters in
particular okay right sure so
being licensed means that
someone is not allowed to do that work
correct unless they have the license
right well they can't legally do it the
light the advantage legally yeah well I
won't let you finish your question after
I give you a little tip so there's
really no difference in terms of the
level of competence between a licensed
person and a certified person in some
case even a registered person like a
registered nurse the license says you
can legally do it in this state and you
can't do it legally without the license
and the license can the advantage of the
licenses it could be suspended or
revoked for misconduct incompetence and
so forth
right but in particular court reporters
so
the person hiring a court reporter is an
attorney right a very experienced you
know or a judge right very very
experienced person so
aren't they competent to judge who they
want to hire on their own why do they
need us as a state to say this person is
hirable for that job and this person
isn't
as opposed to let them make the decision
just like I make a decision when I hire
somebody to fix my car or do all kinds
of other things that are unlicensed
well and that's an interesting
philosophical discussion to have the
thing is if you know
who that person is and you've dealt with
him or her before
and you ha and you have trust in that
person
then you're going to go back to them if
they're not over charging or whatever
but how about if the person has a
problem with substance abuse or uh is is
very competent but they're kind of
dishonest in terms of what they're
charging you for and so forth now that's
a situation where you might want to
bring that person in
because they're doing something that's
illegal so that's that's one of the
things about a license that you can take
it away from a person if they're not
meeting the totality of their
responsibilities not merely to to fix
your car engine or fix your ticker
but also to be honest and maybe not
engage in misuse of substances or
something like that so
all right seeing no further questions
for the representative I appreciate the
opportunity I really appreciate your
comments good to see you keep up the
good work good to see you
thanks again we can move to your handout
perfect
um and again for the record Lindsay
Courtney I'm the executive director of
The Office of professional ice Insurance
certification
and I appreciate the opportunity what I
just wanted to do is go through
factually what I have observed
um HB to uh proposing to do we've spent
a lot of time going through the language
here in the office looking at
legislative history and I thought it
might be useful to the to the division
um so on page two uh here's an overview
it's pretty much uh what we included in
our press release but um I always filled
two proposes to establish Universal
licensure recognition this was also
overwhelmingly supported by the house I
think that was House Bill 594
that also proposes to allow the office
to issue licenses to individuals from
out of states it proposes to transfer
certain boards to the office merge and
reduce certain board sizes eliminate
certain license types eliminate certain
boards and then add one additional
license type
in terms of universal licensure
recognition we've already had an
experiment
in this state regarding
Universal licensure recognition and that
was during covid-19 and during covid-19
State of Emergency the governor
authorized the office to issue emergency
licenses and the criteria was limited to
one they had to have a similar license
at another state they had to be in good
standing and we were able to increase
the number of licensed Health Care
Professionals 22
000 and we had we received fewer than 10
complaints and we've only had one
reported disciplinary action and I think
that was real data that helped
demonstrate that the public would not be
at significant Risk by allowing us to
issue these licenses if they've been
vetted in other states and we are able
to issue them in about 24 hours and so
that makes us a little much more
competitive with our sister States like
Vermont who's already doing this and so
the house bill 2 proposes to codify this
process success and allow us to issue
emergency permanent licenses based on
the same criteria so what I've included
in the subsequent Pages looks like
through Page seven are really just some
charts of the data that we saw during
the emergency licensure
experiment and I really wanted to draw
your attention to the mental health
Fields because we we saw a significant
increase in the number of licensed
professionals when we modified the
criteria to be just that you had a
license in another state that was in
good standing in particular during the
state of emergency 36 percent of latex
were like were licensed here only on an
emergency license 45 almost half of
clinical Mental Health Counselors were
practicing only on an emergency license
uh 44 again almost half of individuals
licensed in New Hampshire to practice
clinical social work we're doing so on
an emergency license and then with
respect to psychologists 63 percent of
individuals who are authorized to
practice here we're doing so on an
emergency license and so certainly the
structural change that's proposed this
portion of the structural change that's
proposed in House Bill 2 is a
significant change but it's a change
that's already being accepted in New
Hampshire and certainly accepted by the
house and so I don't think is that
controversial at least not now we did
attempt to request this bill last year
and it didn't make its way out of
committee
page eight
yes represent Maguire please on page six
physician
65 percent what does that mean
so that data that data references that
65 percent of individuals licensed
practice medicine during the state of
emergency were doing so only on an
emergency license the reason why I don't
think that with respect to Physicians
and Physicians only that data actually
accurately captures what we're looking
at is because we worked with the
Department of Health and Human Services
to license all of their Medicaid
enrolled Physicians who were in
Massachusetts so that our New Hampshire
constituents could continue to receive
services from massachusetts-based
Physicians and that's why that number is
a little bit higher than what we would
represent a people so
versal licensure recognition
24 hours do you just sort of
compare the licensing requirements in
New Hampshire to those of the other
state just to see how they mesh
or or how does that work yeah so the
license has to be of a similar nature so
for example
um
naturopathic doctors we typically don't
itchy those types of licenses because
the licensing requirements are so so
different and they vary significantly in
the scope of practice in our state is
significantly different allow they're
allowed they have a formulary so we do
have to conduct that analysis but for
most Healthcare professions you know
nursing Physicians it's pretty standard
across
across the country
and you know there from a policy
standpoint when we talk about this in
cosmetology we have 1500 hours
requirements well if they're coming from
a state that has a thousand hours but
they work for 10 years
it should be sufficient for the most
part
um so we do engage in that analysis but
um we are able to issue them in a fast
so in terms of the board transfers on
page 8 how spill two proposes to
transfer auctioneers from the Secretary
of State's office their boxing and
wrestling commission from the Secretary
of State's office
bondsman from Secretary of States and
then the board of Licensing for
interpreters for the deaf deafblind and
hard of hearing that's from education
and my understanding is that the purpose
of these transfers is really to increase
efficiency in licensing processes and
eliminate duplication of effort
Statewide
the office is is going is undergoing a
lot of changes and has been in the last
couple of years we are trying to
standardize the way we do business just
today we
um we had a final proposal before jail
car to have one universal licensure
application
um initial application to include
demographic information probably doesn't
sound uh you know that fantastic but
it's taken us years to get to a point
where we can capture the same type of
demographic information if you go to
page nine we are working on several
major strategic goals the first two are
really leveraging technology and I think
the idea behind putting all licensing
boards within oplc is that we will be
able to
all licensing boards will be able to
benefit from the procurement of these
additional Technologies and we
anticipate our new licensing portal to
be in effect
my understanding with respect to the
boards and the Secretary of State's
office is that the secretary of state
has no objection
um I'm not aware of what um doe believes
on page 10 there are several proposed
board mergers
and as representative McGuire mentioned
House Bill 655 as amended and passed out
of the house I believe yesterday
would allow oplc to issue licenses in
between board meetings and this uh House
Bill 655 was the result of a committee
that was established by Senate Bill 330
of last year and they made several
recommendations one of which was to
allow PLC tissue licenses in between
meetings
um as you may know historically the
practice was all applications were
received in paper form all applications
were brought to board meetings monthly
or every 60 days they were reviewed and
then decisions were made and then
licenses were issued or denied as we've
seen
increased demand for licensure
um
Society generally no longer supports
this model
from a Workforce standpoint we are
competing with other states that are
doing business in a different way
particularly Vermont and they do not
have this similar structure and addition
most of our boards have already
delegated the authority to the office to
review applications unless they're
problematic and so
655 and House Bill 2 would propose that
we would issue licenses in between
meetings unless they needed for their
review because of a criminal history
check or disciplinary issue and because
boards would no longer be reviewing
their applications at the monthly
meetings I think I think that's the
justification for the proposed mergers
you no longer need each boards to sit
around the table and divvy up at
licensure applications
so hb2 proposes to merge boards that are
sufficiently similar both to increase
efficiencies and promote collaboration
between professionals we see a lot of
scope of practice that's somewhat
similar across several different boards
and I think the idea is that to promote
collaboration
certain words are proposed to be merged
in particular on page 11 excuse me
representative McGuire has a question oh
yeah sure so
issuing licenses between meetings so is
this include every kind of license
Physicians for example yeah so we
already do that the Board of Medicine
has already authorized us to do that
so um so the proposed board mergers are
The Advisory Board of reflexology with
The Advisory Board of massage I just
wanted to note that there are 17
reflexologists 12 structural integrators
and four Asian Bodywork therapists
Nationwide these disciplines are often
combined and I will circulate this
PowerPoint along with the attachment
um
with respect to latex obviously we've
had some conversations here in
representative McGuire presented on this
issue there are two states that
currently combine psychology with other
disciplines Kansas and Texas
um I've had lengthy discussions with the
executive director over at in Texas and
you know I do believe if implemented
here it it would be
um certainly feasible it's working well
in Texas
the third proposal would be to merge the
Board of Medicine with the board of
Podiatry and medical reviews
subcommittee
with respect to the medical review
subcommittee I wanted to note that the
Board of Medicine
um
supports removing the medical review
subcommittee out of statute
they want a peer review committee and we
support that and and would recommend
allowing them to establish that via rule
but there are some significant issues
with the MRC now because it's currently
constituted it's currently in statute
and they are governor and Council
appointments and the problem right now
is uh they meet half the time they
cancel almost you know over half of
their meetings they get through a
handful of cases at every meeting and we
get over 200 cases a year and so there's
significant backlog and because the
statute does not allow the Board of
Medicine to provide oversight we
essentially are stuck with people who
are who are not
um who are not fulfilling their duties
and so I did want to make that comment
with respect to the mrsc in terms of the
Board of Medicine and board of Podiatry
the New Hampshire Board of Medicine
currently regulates three disciplines
MDS Do's or osteopaths and PAs physician
assistants 11 states use one board to
regulate multiple disciplines that
include Podiatry
and you see those there and currently
the New Hampshire Board of Podiatry is a
five-member board there were 91 of them
in New Hampshire
Engineers with land surveyors both
boards are currently supported by the
National Council of examiners for
engineering and surveying and 36 states
have combined boards nine states only
nine states have Standalone engineering
boards most of them are fairly large but
you see Vermont obviously is not a large
board also I would mention that Vermont
uses the advisory model that we
discussed earlier
almost all their boards are advisory and
we can get into that a little bit later
but it's it's a model that's used
Nationwide ah here we go page 12
proposed advisory boards
so smaller boards and this is no I mean
this is true for any profession it's not
about a particular profession but
smaller boards are at greatest risk of
antitrust issues
um everybody knows everybody everybody
knows who you know who's doing what and
with respect to policy autonomous boards
that are comprised primarily of active
Market participants and those are people
in the profession
um they that's our Supreme Court or not
our Supreme Court the United States
Supreme Court has said that they are not
entitled to immunity and so this puts
the state at potential risk of liability
if they were to make decisions based on
a competitive nature and it it does
happen so I mean I won't go into
significant details about it but it is
it is an issue and that's why a lot of
states have moved in the direction of
providing State oversight
what the United States Supreme Court
said in that case was that in order to
be entitled to immunity States need to
provide
oversight and supervision by an actor
that is not part of that particular
profession so some states have like veto
power some states have moved in The
Advisory model some states you know use
other different models but that really
is the basis for the advisory model
approach because of the fact that the
executive director who's not a member of
this profession essentially has veto
power it provides the state with
immunity that we wouldn't otherwise have
so excuse me representative McGuire is a
question yes thank you so could
just to make this clear what's an advice
or full board and what's an Advisory
Board could you give us an example based
on the page that our chairman was was
looking at which was acupuncture
right so acupuncture is one that's now a
full board and by House Bill 2 would
become an Advisory board so could you
walk us through an example of somebody
has a complaint and it goes to the board
and how it's done now how it would be
done in the future
um and what are the qualifications of
the people who work for you that would
be working on it and making those
decisions and so on certainly
um page 104 it's there's not a
108 I think is where you were looking no
well yeah there's a couple of sections
but
um 104 108 but it eliminates board
altogether it doesn't say an Advisory
Board it's just executive director
that's that's exactly it when it when it
takes out the word board and puts in the
word executive director it's for a board
that's becoming advisory yes correct
there's a separate section that
establishes an Advisory Board and sets
forth what the executive director has to
utilize that Advisory board for could
you point that section out to us
um I could send that along to your
representative I apologize I didn't
bring my hard copy of hb2
um
I I can I can send it along but that's
that's how it works now for the existing
advisory boards there's one statute that
says
um is that Advisory board established
these are their qualifications but the
authority lies with the executive
director and the reason for that is
because the executive director
um is not a part of that particular
profession and that's what gives the
state immunity when they're um that's
what allows the state to provide
effective oversight of I understand I
know I'm just like going forward that's
my question that you're going to send me
yeah Mr Hoffman
point out this you can point out this
section to Mr Hoffman Mr chair uh
director Courtney were was what you were
saying that you currently have the
format with the advisory boards now and
so what you're doing is you're expanding
the use of that
oversight format to more boards correct
we already utilize and I can discuss how
we how we do it but we already have that
process in place
so you are referring to page 109
yes
see where it made a reference to this
advice report it just said the executive
director
I know it's in there oh here we go
um
so line 22 board established the
executive director shall establish an
Advisory Board
so it's Fourth that one shall be a
certified acupuncture detoxification
specialist into Shelby licensed
acupuncturists
and they shall advise the executive
director regarding the implementation of
so in practice how we've done it
um
so there's really no distinction in
terms of how we manage complaints in the
office now when we get a complaint for
most boards unless they really want to
see complaints in advance all of the
complaints go to the enforcement
Division and the enforcement division
will request a response from the
licensee unless it's considered an
emergency which is usually diversion of
drugs or stealing money or something
like that and then they get a response
from the licensee and it goes to the
regulatory body
in this case I don't
I myself or the hearings officer we
don't even see the complaint or the
response we convene The Advisory Board
and they make a recommendation as to
whether or not to proceed to discipline
and typically we go along with that
recommendation there's only been one
instance that I can think of where we
did not go along with that
recommendation and it was a legal reason
because we didn't think we had
jurisdiction over it
um so in any event uh they will make a
decision or a recommendation to proceed
to disciplinary action we issue a notice
appearing and the case is prosecuted I
have to say that I think some advisory
boards not all some like that model
because it provides them cover in a
small community
some of them like nursing home
administrators my understanding is they
don't object to being an Advisory Board
they don't like making legal decisions
they also don't like being in a small
community and being the ones solely
responsible
for you know disciplining their
colleagues and so it does provide a
little cover for those for those
individuals so I would say some like it
some some don't
um but generally the process works
really well and it's consistent with
whether other states do
I guess I'm just not as smart as you are
no I don't think that's the case
representative language but just going
back to the language it says The
Advisory Board shall advise the
executive director regarding the
implementation of this chapter certainly
that are going again going to uh
page 108 there's nothing about The
Advisory Board participating in
discipline that's my concern and yeah I
see your concern you can certainly
change the language to be shall consult
with participate we
we don't we don't object to anything
like that it's our practice to bring
them in because they are the experts in
their field now I will say some cases
are really cut and dry you know for
massage we often get complaints of
sexual assaults so those are frequent
you don't necessarily need expertise for
that but we do we do consult with them
um
but uh you could certain we could
certainly make that modification and we
would support that modification to be
crystal clear that they have to be
it's been my concern that it's a little
vague right now because there has been
involvement but this is pretty clear
language it's bold to know that the
board is gone and the executive director
is completely responsible for discipline
so maybe if it said in consultation with
this Advisory board but yeah I think
that needs to be tightened up but yeah I
think we would support that language and
I know that I think it was
representative shoe it has been adding
that uh to pretty much every bill that
we have and we support that
so with respect to uh so staying on page
12 though
um you see the list of of words that are
proposed to move to or convert to
advisory boards all of them have fewer
than 200 licensees
um
and
I understand there may be some fear
regarding you know moving to advisor is
one step closer to being repealed
that is not I mean from my perspective
um that's not the case again House Bill
2 is on oplc's Bill we requested to
convert mirt in particular to an
Advisory Board last year because there
were significant core problems and we
had licenses that we couldn't issue and
we had disciplinary actions that we
couldn't take any action on and so but
that issue is completely separate and
distinct from whether or not the
profession should be licensed and I
personally don't see these licenses
going away
um
so getting into the proposed repeals I
think it's on page 14. I just wanted to
provide you with what we were able to
come up with in terms of research may or
may not be helpful to you
um Foresters
originally licensed actually second time
licensed in 1990 they had been
previously licensed but during a sunset
review this this body actually repealed
their relationship for about 11 years
the requirements are essentially just
education although there are exemptions
for that experience in an examination
um based on our available data the state
hasn't denied licenses to individual and
there's only been one reported
disciplinary matter
um I think if the license was repealed
the state could certainly rely on
voluntary National certification there
is a national certification Society of
American Foresters and I've included
based on the Society of American
Foresters
a map of which states do license uh
Foresters most in the Northeast and
backing up a little bit to like the
medical licensure certainly had that
medical license technician over the
Exeter Hospital yes issued did you
create a new license to try to deal with
that or how did that all work out oh
representative McGuire I guess I struck
a nerve there
uh yes I have to say that was before
director Courtney was involved
at that time
there was a
registration required not a license
there were no technical qualifications
at all
the sponsor specifically said to Edna
that the reason for the registration was
to be a hassle to the individuals so
that bad actors would not come to New
Hampshire
uh
despite
my opposition among others
the slight this registration was put
into place
and it was retained even though
the hospital in under question in that
one incident was found to be at fault
for not supervising him properly
uh it was the like the licensure was
maintained on the basis of that single
anecdotal
that one bad actor and I don't believe
that there were any significant cases of
we have a little pause here I just like
to recognize any of the division members
if we have any questions as we move
along thank you chairman chair Maguire
the only thing I would add is um I start
I wasn't at oplc during that time but I
did represent half of the plaintiffs in
that case as a practicing attorney
um and I can say having gone through
tens of thousands of pages of Discovery
documents that registration would not
have prevented what happened at Exeter
Hospital and the reason for that is
because what happened at Exeter Hospital
is that just nobody reported uh
misconduct and our licensure laws and
disciplinary
setup it requires people to report it's
reactive not proactive so it would not
have made a difference
in my opinion
um
so if we had had licensure required for
that Tech position
uh I guess it would just be speculation
that that would have not occurred but I
personally I mean
I've I've reviewed again over 65 000
pages of documents and I can send you an
article that really that I've written
that tracks what happened with that case
I mean he went from state to state to
state and no State ever you know when he
was observed passed out in a back
bathroom with a needle syringe in his
arm never reported it
um the authorities law enforcement never
followed up on it and so uh criminal
history checks wouldn't have done
anything uh licensure wouldn't have done
anything because it was just never
reported
um he was he went to the next state
where he reoffended
um before action could be taken and I
think States probably just felt oh he's
out of our jurisdiction it's probably
not worth our resources
all right so moving right along yes to
Foresters I just provide a difference uh
because you know there's been a lot of
conversation between National
certification versus State licensure so
here's a synopsis of what the national
certification
um requirements are education you have
to have at least a bachelor's degree and
you have to have certain experience at
least five or more years
there are continuing education
requirements there are ways to file
complaints and you do have an
opportunity to search for certified
professionals interestingly then you
have your state licensure requirements
appear to be less than the national
certification requirements
we actually
allow individuals with with two-year
degrees
and if you have eight years of
experience you don't need any
educational experience at all we do
require an examination
um that it that appears to be the main
distinction
with Foresters
moving on to page 16 the Allied Health
governing board so the Allied Health
governing board essentially functioned
how oplc functions now they had
Authority
the Allied Health governing board is
comprised of the board chair of all of
the other governing boards like the
occupational government you know therapy
governing board physical therapy and
they enacted procedural rules
but that Authority is now with oplc and
so there really is no purpose
um for that board this board does not
issue any licenses
with respect to Landscape Architects all
states licensed Landscape Architects I
think New Hampshire was the 47th state
that began licensing Landscape
Architects that was in 2006 and I will
forward you the finance committee
hearing report
um licensure is mandatory you know there
are some exceptions but it is mandatory
and it's misdemeanor if you're required
to be licensing or not there are certain
requirements for licensure obviously
education experience and exam and that's
the exam is through Clark
according to our available data we've
had zero applicants be denied and zero
Enforcement cases and I know that the
seals are very important to individuals
licensees May purchase a seal noting
that they're licensed this is not
something our office gives out they they
do it on their own
so if hb2 passed us proposed obviously
the board and the license would be
eliminated I think the public could rely
on voluntary National certification
and previously uh to licensure a lot of
licensed individuals sought licensure in
other states because they wanted the
seal and they would just buy their seal
and note that they were licensed
elsewhere so I think that could happen
as it did prior to 2006 if hb2 passed as
proposed
moving on to Natural scientists of
course as you're aware there has been
significant pushback from the community
um and interestingly I believe you heard
that I think the association is
supportive of merging with the board of
Architects
um
natural scientists created in 1997
there have only been three Enforcement
cases and I have to say that if
excuse me representative yes yes well
emerging Landscape Architects with the
board of Architects The Architects don't
like it oh certainly certainly I don't I
so in terms of natural scientists we've
only had three Enforcement cases two
honestly I
there may be a constitutional issue here
the two were in 2015 they were related
to continuing education the person was
essentially voluntary voluntarily
surrendered their license which is
pretty significant
um because they didn't do CES the third
one was a voluntary surrender due to a
conviction
um and I really don't think that under
this the new statute that we have that
they that that would have been an issue
um but in any event if House Bill 2 were
passed the state could rely on voluntary
credentials
um several states do one for soil
scientists would be the soil science
Society of America or Society of wetland
scientists and on the following page
with respect to soil scientists I give a
breakdown of what the national
certification does versus what the New
Hampshire state certification does
and again in um they're they're pretty
comparable in both cases they may file
compliances and there's an opportunity
for uh for consumers to search for
certified professionals
with respect to Wetland which is on 21
again pretty comparable
um
this organization notes that individuals
can purchase a seal which I know is
important to licensees if they have the
national certification they also do that
if they have the New Hampshire
certification
so getting back to medical technicians
which is on page 22 this was created in
response I believe to that
hepatitis C outbreak at Exeter Hospital
essentially what it does is it Regis it
requires individuals who are not
otherwise licensed who may come into
contact with a controlled drug to
register with our office
it's pretty Broad
and the issue that we have now and we
had proposed last year moving them to an
Advisory Board is that they haven't met
in over two years
and so uh it's essentially not
functioning as it was intended so I
think something needs to happen with
respect to this either way
um
we could I could not find any other
states that have a similar registration
requirement I know some states
separately from nursing assistance
register people who have direct access
to patients but I couldn't find another
similar registration in another state
except for Illinois so
um
it I will say that the criteria is very
Broad and very vague so it's it's
possible that they exist and just my
um in terms of court reporters on page
23 again they're currently an Advisory
Board and we just uh probably just
enacted their their new rules there are
about 66 court reporters
um again uh requirements for their
initial licensure are listed uh on this
page includes a national certification
they are not required to maintain their
National certification
um I will say that the Advisory Board uh
is is
strongly against D licensure 24 states
have either voluntary or no
certification for court reporters
um
one thing that The Advisory Board
brought up I think it could be addressed
within an amendment uh to House Bill 2
was that if they if their licensure was
repealed they would lose their limited
notarial function and they felt that was
important to them so I think essentially
a grandfathering could address that
issue to allow them to continue to
I will also say in practice in New
Hampshire
attorneys typically administer OS when
you go into other jurisdictions It's
usually the court reporter but in New
Hampshire
um New Hampshire attorneys typically
administer those
uh the manufactured housing complaint
board that's on page 24 this is not a
licensure board essentially this board
is intended to act as an Arbiter or some
sort of adjudicative body for disputes
between the manufactured housing Park
and tenant this is not something I think
this has
I think the intent is very good I just
don't think it it's not being utilized
the Department of Justice has concurrent
jurisdiction I did confirm with them
that the Consumer Protection Bureau has
jurisdiction over these cases it's my
understanding that the chair of that
particular board
has no opposition to this board being
eliminated
that said there's a bill pending in the
Senate that I think would would modify
this and there's been some concern
expressed by members of the public
regarding Medical Imaging on page 25
this also was created in 2016. now there
are 10 permanent license types many
different temporary licenses so the
majority of those that are proposed to
be repealed are under this board it is
an Advisory Board
um
I will say that the requirements for
Education are pretty standard they need
a certain level of Education a national
exam and typically for most license
types they do need a national
certification
we haven't had too many issues with
respect to those applicants one
applicant per permanent licensure has
been denied and there's been one
enforcement matter
I will say as a practical matter not all
states license these folks and so that
has become an issue particularly for
endorsement or reciprocity in order to
take advantage of our temporary
licensure you need to have a license in
another state and many of these folks do
not and so when they come in we cannot
issue them a credential or a license
pretty quickly they have to go through
the whole process and for these folks a
lot of them are traveling healthcare
workers so when they come into our state
you know maybe on a weekend to assist
it's not just for you know I'm going to
move here so these are pretty mobile
folks and so that aspect is pretty
problematic I was able to find that
states really approached this license
type in various different ways I think
Massachusetts lumps them all together in
one particular license type which is
problematic for the reasons I just
described
um but you know sonographers are really
my licensed in four states that said
radiographers are licensed in 42 States
so there's a list right there for your
consideration
I think if House Bill 2 were to pass we
would do what we did prior to 2016 which
is that Healthcare facilities would
continue to require that individuals
have National certification and they
would also require individuals to
undergo criminal history checks and
Health Care Facilities would be
uh turning to almost at the end
licensure nursing assistance there's
been a lot of conversation about this
um
under the proposal New Hampshire would
still be required to register nursing
assistance as we're required to do
I could not find any state other than
New Hampshire that requires both
registration and licensure of nursing
assistance many states refer to
individuals on the registry as being
CNAs or certified nursing assistants
New Hampshire could choose to eliminate
this duplicative licensure requirement
but allow nursing assistance to utilize
a different title I know title is is
very important we've heard that in
testimony
and the following page I just wanted to
give you a brief comparison of what the
nursing assistant registry is and what
the license is
so for the register you have to complete
a criminal history check that's in DHHS
regs
you have to complete a state approved
nursing assistant program under CMS regs
it has to be at least 75 hours our regs
are 100 hours notably 13 states exceed
us significantly by at least 2 20
percent
you have to pass a state approved exam
and you have to complete at least 12
hours of in-service training per year
on the licensure side you have here are
the requirements you have to be on the
registry and you have to complete a CBC
and you have to pay fees and you have to
complete
24 hours of CES over the course of two
years
on page 30 this outlines the process of
what a nursing aide has to go through in
order to get licensed they first have to
enroll in a nursing assistant program
that's board approved and that requires
the criminal history check then they
complete the program
then they complete the competency
evaluation then they're placed on the
registry
and then they have to apply for the
license they have to pay the fee and
they have to complete the criminal
history check and then their issued a
license and I think under House Bill 2
what this would do was essentially
eliminate the last two boxes in this
process
we had previously proposed to the board
of nursing or requested that the Board
of Nursing consider just eliminating the
fee because that would allow us to use
the licensure as the registry
um
basically cutting our administrative
obligations in half the Board of Nursing
at that time didn't want to eliminate
the fee because the fee was important in
terms of making the
lnas feel valued so we didn't eliminate
the fee
but it was our position that if we were
to eliminate the fee we could
essentially merge these two
because the CMS regulations prohibit us
from charging a fee to be on the
registry and that's because the state is
so I have a quick question you you
um have mentioned many times about
combining boards because of lack of
attendance can't get people there I know
a number of boards like the prescription
drug affordability board
um meet online often has that been
discussed to get people together versus
eliminating the board but allow people
to visually hold their hearings or
meetings yes 91a does not presently
allow a quorum of a board to attend
virtually we do live stream our meetings
but uh all public bodies are required to
have a quorum physically present in
order to conduct a meeting in compliance
with 91a one of the recommendations that
came out of that committee that was
established by incentive Bill 330 was to
allow our licensure boards to conduct
virtual meetings we saw increased
attendance when that happened during
covid-19
and there was a bill last year that
would propose that but because you know
it there you wouldn't be changing it
necessarily just for oplc boards it
would be for all public bodies
um that didn't pass
hmm
but would it be helpful if it did in if
one of the issues is the Quorum issue
and if you could loosen up the
restrictions a little bit on remote
meetings would that be helpful and
getting the meetings to take place
certainly that was our position last
year as well and we had data that was
able to support increased attendance
Additionally you know it's difficult to
get public members it's also difficult
to get people from other parts of the
state
um and it's actually more expensive for
us to reimburse mileage costs so we
saved a significant almost a hundred
thousand dollars when we didn't have to
pay for mileage which is you know no
small
chunk of change for us
so just as a general matter who is
appointing the public members
it's the governor and Council for most
appointments and what I can say is we
have a really hard time finding public
members interested in serving we send
out for uh for our board members who are
licensed professionals we send out email
blasts but there's no body of people
that we can send out you know request to
to apply we don't get a lot of
applications and I know that the
governor's office doesn't have a lot of
public member applications just sitting
there it's just really challenging to
find those individuals
representative McGuire thank you yes
looking at page 30. so you're saying
that if if House Bill 2 passed as is the
last two boxes would be eliminated but
someone to get into the registry would
still have done all the training and and
been evaluated and so on correct
um how does someone get off the registry
yeah a complaint process or something
like that yeah so we're required
um to
follow a process
so you can get off the registry by not
working as a nurse aide within the last
two years when you have to renew
or there's a disciplinary matter
involving fraud waste abuse and I have
to say that the majority of LNA cases
that we have are fraudway surveys and so
there would be you know a finding and
you could essentially be deemed not
eligible to serve as a nursing assistant
man so so
therefore there is a still even if the
last two boxes are eliminated there's
still a disciplinary feature right so
yeah yes okay so your your suggestion
was call somebody who's on the registry
in LNA
and we're done is that
kind of yeah I mean that's what we've
heard is a concern during public
testimony is that sense of professional
identity
um and I think that was true with the
committee report that was issued in 2019
and
from you know I think you could
other states call them CNAs
some states call them Nas
and as a follow-up to representative
McGuire where is the disciplinary
procedure found in your proposal
in this proposal yes since you're making
those changes I would assume that or
where is your disciplinary procedure
that you follow yeah ours are in our PLC
200s which I could send to you it's a
standardized way that we um conduct both
investigations and hearings
um I can certainly send those to you I
don't think other than with respect to
the advisory boards these changes do not
propose a change in how we conduct
disciplinary proceedings
so you mentioned the governor and
Council are responsible for the
appointing of some of the positions
now there's one a mediation board or
something and there are like five
mediators and that's being reduced to
one
uh and the governor and Council would
not be part of that but again it's an
executive director that would be
appointing that mediator how does
why not five and why go to one
um that board is very different
um unlike most boards that are required
to be nominated by the governor and
appointed by executive Council or
confirmed by executive Council that has
separate
um private entities and or members of
the court and or members of the
legislature who are required to sit I
think there's only 47 licensees in the
board is I want to say about 10 people
I'll get you to specific numbers and
from my perspective it's largely
dysfunctional
um
and there needs to be some oversight
there
are there any further questions might
take a little break here seeing none I
guess continue if you would thanks sure
I'm almost done so page 31 is just a
graphic of what our state requires our
state requires 100 hours and a lot of 13
other states require more training for
nursing assistance actually Maine
requires 180 which is interesting and
they don't have a licensure requirement
uh booths we've already talked about
this
um the Board of barbering cosmetology
anesthetics supports this based on my
research this came around the time of
um as actually a mechanism to empower
females uh women business owners
um they could operate their own business
years years ago and but from our
perspective the shop is already licensed
what happens practically is you may have
10 boost within a licensed shop our
inspector has to go out to one booth
inspect everything come back go out to
another Booth inspect everything come
back and do that 11 times and it's
incredibly ineffective
um
so the only difference between a booth
and a shop is that the booth doesn't
have to have the booth itself doesn't
have to have running water because the
representative could you please come to
you could just speak into the mic please
thanks right sorry
I just want to be clear because it says
proposes to remove requirement that
independent contractors within license
shopped shops be licensed so to me it
reads that the hairdressers don't need
to be licensed no so the booth in order
to operate a booth know you have to be
an independent contractor
not employed and that's a labor issue
that really should be a DOL issue that
our inspectors have been inspecting
but what we are saying that is that you
okay the statute does the proposed
statute does I I I hear what you're
saying
um yeah so
um
but again the Board of barbering is
fully supportive of that because the
booth licensure does not help facilitate
increased public protection
and then finally I wanted to address the
issue of The Proposal regarding massage
therapy establishment licensure this has
been before this body numerous times
including this year
um
but it continues to be problematic
our massage therapy licensure laws and
this is an Advisory board so this is
directly regulated by the agency with
the advice of three massage therapists
it does not allow us to effectively
adjudicate
um or help prevent our licensure laws
from being utilized to facilitate sex
and labor trafficking
um it's a serious problem that's
happening Nationwide and I gave you some
statistics from the Federation of State
Massage Therapy boards
um between 6 500 and 9000 enlisted
businesses use massage or Bodywork as a
front for prostitution in the United
States our current disciplinary and
investigative
framework only allows us to be reactive
we can't conduct inspections because we
don't have establishment licensure on
the few times that we've gotten
complaints we've gone out there I can
tell you stories people running out the
back and then they just stop working in
that particular area and they set up
shop down the street and we have
received licensure applications from
certain parts of the country that we
know
likely are our
are producing uh folks who are coming
here to be trafficked but there's
nothing in our massage therapy licensure
laws that allow me to say you're from
Flushing New York this is a problem and
I can't check up on that because we
don't have establishment licensure
and I think that this um
okay
it just needs to be it needs to be
addressed on page 34 you can see a map
yeah it's also proposed to be in house
yes that was one of the edits in the
first amendment I brought because based
on the results on House Bill 341 the
house position is the massage
establishments do not need licensure
therefore we deleted it from house bill
2.
it well representative groda looks like
she has a comment that's your opinion no
it it was not a consent uh calendar item
it was it was debated and fought on the
floor but the result was the house bill
341 was was killed and therefore that's
the house position
foreign
with full respect to all different
professions you know it's proposed that
we retain licensure Foresters we retain
licensure of natural scientists very
important but there are no issues with
child sex trafficking
there's a clear public protection issue
with respect to massage therapy and the
fact that our laws are facilitating this
conduct in our state and so if the house
is going to take the position that we
should continue to license certain
technical professions because it would
be too difficult to do repeals of other
ordinances or people need seals why are
we not establishing massage
establishment licensure when there is a
known sex trafficking issue in our state
so that would be my only comment
I have to address that with all the
members that voted against uh 341. well
this is another opportunity
well there may be a conflict because
often we don't put house positions that
aren't supported in the finance budget
so yes I mean the
the most convincing argument I believe
against House Bill 341 is that The
Regulators should not be used to enforce
Criminal Just sanctioned criminal
Behavior it six trafficking is a crime
child abuse is a crime
we don't want the licensing clerks to go
there and say oh my goodness it looks
like there's sex trafficking going on
they don't have the skills they they
aren't aren't trained for it we want law
enforcement to deal with with criminal
issues
I would just say that
um and I appreciate the House's position
and this has been fully vetted
um
the reason why we have administrative
regulations and specifically licensures
to protect the public and we frequently
run across uh criminal activity just had
one the other day significant
embezzlement issues we refer that to law
enforcement but we still continue with
our administrative action because we
shouldn't be allowing those people to
practice and work in New Hampshire if
there's a significant public health
safety risk and by establishing massage
establishment licensure like we have
with salons that don't have it
demonstrated
issue with trafficking it allows us to
conduct inspections and make sure that
that that it's on the up and up that
people are are performing services in a
sanitized Manner and that our licensees
are are doing what they need to be doing
and that they're
they're not being besmerged by the fact
that people are coming in and utilizing
our licensure authority to conduct
criminal Behavior representative would
so I'm I'm finally understanding this so
the the well to me this whole exercise
is proof of why this is way too
complicated for us to get done in the
next two days but so massage therapists
can be are are required to be licensed
but the establishments in which they
work are not is that right and so what
happens is uh somebody will open up a
massage therapy shop and that it could
be somebody who is trafficking in people
from this day to perform services that
are not massage therapy they may or may
not go and purchase massage therapy
transcripts that look
real
um and then they traffic in typically
women and that and then when somebody
becomes aware of what's going on they
move on to another jurisdiction and
because we don't have inspection
Authority unless we've received a
complaint there's no way for us to go in
and determine that they're complying
with the regulations
represented grow to please
you'll notice that I did not mention
this when I spoke with you
it is because although it is my bill
and our committee sent you to the floor
without recommendation and the house did
not approve it
I did not want to appear
that I would be biased in asking you to
keep that in house bill 2. I want my
testimony to rest only on its merits
so that's why I didn't include it
is I think I've provided my opinion and
I made it happy to take any other
questions I appreciate I very much
appreciate your time I know I've taken
up a lot of it
um
so now I'll go just strictly to the
finance piece I'm sure there's uh that
you've included we've seen this number
before that yes your proposal would
eliminate
about nine hundred and fifty thousand
dollars coming back to the state
how do you intend to
fund your
new proposal with increased fees because
you're obviously not going to let any
staff go I didn't see a reduction of
Staff in your budget proposal
um so our proposal was prior to hb2
coming out so the agency obviously had
to submit its proposal based on the
current statutory framework
I'm not convinced that you know if you
eliminate the license types that are
proposed to be eliminated including the
duplicative nature of Licensing nursing
assistance that's a significant amount
of work
um so I'm not convinced that we would
require as much administrative support
and would likely see some changes in
reductions and expenditures as a result
we do need to look at fees and part of
that is because many boards are paying
way more than they should and many
boards are not paying enough cosmetology
being a prime example we haven't been
able to level set those fees yet because
we required statutory changes which we
just received
um
so we do plan on doing that I don't
anticipate significant increases in fees
as a result
representative Carol McGuire followed by
yes thank you Mr chair I'd like to
mention that we had a bill House Bill
that would
keep
the
um create a non-lapsing fund for the
license fees during the hearings on that
we heard that oplc typically
lapses several million dollars back to
the general fund so that the license
fees at their current level are more
more than enough even after that million
dollar reduction are adequate to cover
the cost of
of the operations without assuming any
of the efficiencies that we are
confident will happen
so
no I just caught our eye that would be a
substantial reduction of nearly a
million dollars and what was coming back
to the state that's all uh yes
but the house bill 445 making that a
non-lapsing fund has passed the house it
is currently in ways and means
for their analysis and we'll see what
comes out of them they're the experts on
funding from an Eda point of view we
felt that allowing large amounts of
money from license fees to lapse to the
general fund
beyond the cost of operating the office
and doing in doing everything else
that's necessary turns the license fee
into a tax and we've had information
that is
uh unconstitutional and not allowed
well representative Dan Maguire for some
we don't have income tax so I didn't I
heard we had an income tax from you just
the other day yeah except except for the
IND tax anyways uh all right where was
it going so did I hear you say that
you don't think the fee that L A's pay
thirty five dollars and the average cost
of a two-year license is 155. now the
Board of Nursing has decided that it
would like to subsidize lnas but the
Board of Nursing is obviously they also
haven't raised their fees in a while the
RNs pay 80 and the aprns pay I believe
100 and 100
um and so
I'm you know I'd have to look at the
numbers again today but I'm not sure
that the Board of Nursing is covering
its costs and and so there's probably a
lot more lnas than the other types of
nurses also yes I believe there are 12
000 lnas certainly not that many that
are currently practicing
um I think if if the licensure were
eliminated we would be able to better
calculate the amount of work that we are
doing to register these individuals and
we would be able to
seek more funding from the federal
government I don't think we're getting
what we are entitled to under their
regulations in order to manage their
registry but because the the
administrative process is just too
intertwined we haven't been able to
other questions from uh division members
representative evil well I just noticed
on page 36 you did say that there's a
potential increase in revenue from the
universal licensure
yeah I think so because we saw when we
instituted those changes uh we saw an
increase of 10 in the number of licenses
Statewide so I would anticipate that by
reducing barriers increasing portability
that we would see people taking
advantage of that another question yeah
and then as far as all the different
boards that are being converted
eliminated
did did they have input into the
decisions that are embodied in hb2 now
well seeing no yes representative grassy
please just just one comment I just
wanted to point out that it was my bill
that I introduced back in 1979 that
created the licensure for massage
therapist oh thank you
and originally or I don't know if
originally but we used to have massage
may have been in the bill it's been a
long time yes so
thank you for your time well thank you
very much who appreciated the division
will make a decision next week I don't
want to do anything today representative
Hewitt and Sweeney are not here to
participate
um we generally don't allow people from
the public to speak during just work
sessions but I'll Grant you the request
but if you could make it oh no look at
the folks now want to stand up and speak
but
the only thing I would say is I'm happy
to make myself available between now and
whenever if you have any additional
we'll hold you to three minutes so if
I'm Dr Deborah Warner from Littleton as
you know I testified on Monday
um I want to bring up one small
suggestion for this committee is that
um I am
very concerned that these matters are
layering upon your expertise in a
different area and that it is an
incredible burden for you to not only
incorporate all this controversy but
also to have to gear up in the entire
background that a whole other committee
has already
um
chained itself through their bills and
in history of these boards and I might
make a suggestion that if there be any
of these sections between pertaining to
licensure that are controversial and
that there's there's this way in that to
think about it that you might consider
pulling them off anyway because we've
already known that chairwoman Maguire is
ready to incorporate much study in her
committee and there's many people who
are ready to do that work and as you
know I'm one of those little worker bees
who shows up and so I'd give that
suggestion to you I also have a point an
answer
representative leichmann you brought up
several times the issue of having one
person have too much Authority and that
the board's not having that and such
there are in the law currently at least
in our board that many many
rights and due process pieces that are
in the law and these things will be
incorporated into study that the adna
will be doing in their retained Bill and
so I I think that those are an important
consideration is that
the steps involved in the process of
investigation and such that they are
more fully articulated in the law and
that they will be incorporated in that
study
well thanks for your comments uh
and we appreciate your accolades back to
us but I've got a very dedicated group
of folks here and we'll hopefully make
the best decision next week thank you so
much
now the next folks just need two minutes
representative McGuire so I'll get your
clock on yeah
you two gentlemen like I guess are you
if we could have your name please
my name is Randy Knowles I'm a landscape
architect in the current national
trustee for the American society
landscape for the New Hampshire chapter
um I just wanted to make a few quick
points first of all thank you chairman
and you're bored and I'd also like to
take a chance to thank um chairman Carol
McGuire and her board for
uh recommending that Landscape
Architects be removed from the
deregulation portion of house build 2. I
just want to correct a statement that
keeps being made and was made Monday and
last week and director Courtney made it
again there is no National certification
for Landscape Architects there is the
ASLA American side Landscape Architects
and Clark administrates the lare which
is the national exam on a state-by-state
basis
um we are currently licensed in all
states including the District of
Columbia
should you remove us from deregulation I
understand that there will be merging of
boards we are not opposed to that
however
we ask that you look at putting us with
Architects as I said in my statement on
Monday we are Allied professions we the
first two years of the five of each
five-year program you are in the same
classes with fundamentals and design and
all of that and if you look at 38 States
in um the country actually have a joint
Board of Landscape Architects and
architects
um there's been a lot of talk of
overlapping practice ours does overlap
with um more with engineers and
Architects and currently there's an
organization called icor the
international organization Council on
regulations and there in the process of
um coming up with an explanation of how
we all overlap just for states to get a
clearer view on that
um
and I guess I had one question
personally I'm not speaking it for the
ASLA at this point
um but there was a lot of talk of
um you could just go to another state to
be licensed for instance if if licensure
was deregulated
and I went to Massachusetts I would be
forced to take two more additional
portions of the exam one it was totally
based on their Wetlands process because
they obviously want to know you their
processing of Permitting
so I guess
it's very easy for folks to say they
could just go somewhere else and come
back and practice on another stage
license but I do hope that you will
remove us from deregulation
uh thank you very much for your comments
I actually used to hold a restricted use
pesticide license so I know as far as
the reciprocal Arrangements that exist
between other states they're not always
as easy as they sound thank you thank
you yeah representative McGuire has a
question if you take it sure yeah what
are you licensed on any other state
um I do have a main license because I
briefly did some work there 20 years ago
and you don't have to keep paying or you
do I have just because I have it gotcha
now as I understand that in Vermont
there's a very simple ice there's an
advisory type license right so there's
there's no board there's nothing like
that there's just two
they appoint two Landscape Architects to
to advise their version of oplc I'm not
familiar with Vermont okay so all right
thank you very much
all right so ah yes the Timberland
Owners Association
what might he be here to talk about
oh I'll keep it under two minutes and I
I thank you for the opportunity to speak
and then your name please Jason stock
executive director of the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association we
represent Timberland owners and Forest
products industry and
um
I wanna I wanna thank uh chair Maguire
for all the work she's done
um and the her recommendation is to not
eliminate Forester licensing for many
Timberland owners Timberland is their
biggest asset and having a professional
Forester
um someone with an accreditation behind
them and you're entrusting this asset
with them you want to make sure that
there is some level of aptitude or
accreditation there behind them and so
we appreciate that acknowledgment
um we're we are one of the combined
board people
um and I guess we're okay with that uh
although we would prefer we like the
current
current situation and we would prefer
that but if if there isn't a if there is
an effort to
combine boards we're we're fine
um with with what has been proposed our
our only
our only suggestion is right now under
current law there are seven members on
the forester's licensing board we would
drop to two the current law 310 a
colon 100 gets somewhat prescriptive we
felt that talking to our members one of
the feelings is that if you're going to
have just two Foresters we would like to
make sure that a that they are
practicing you know they're actively in
the woods practicing managing Timber
sales that's an important aspect that
there's someone actually out there and
and doing that the other piece is we'd
really like to see a Timberland owner on
the board because that is truly the
consumer that's the individual
purchasing it right now the current
board does require two kind of public
members but they're they're landowners
and we felt that having that landowner
and having that perspective of someone
on the board that understands Timber
sales Timber transactions Etc
lastly when it comes to adjudication and
this gets to the discipline question
that's been raised and and talked about
we really feel that it's important that
if you have a board
um and our initial thought was have a
board have say three members two
Foresters and a landowner if there's an
adjudicative matter that would fall to
them it's kind of a jury of your peers
and so that you're not in a position
where you're asking a wetland or soil
scientist to determine stumpage values
doomage
um you know things of that nature so
that you have professionals basically
adjudicating their peers
um and so with that again our our two
comments for the for the proposal that
has come over is a a in top first and
foremost thank you for retaining the
license B if you're going to have a
board a combined board add have two
Foresters at least ensure at least one
of them is practicing forestry have a
Timberland owner and the third comment
is if there's when it comes to
adjudicative matters have that subset of
that combined board be the Arbiter and
again there was talk about you know in
consultation with the oplc or however
you work that but that to me is the the
key it's that's your jury of your peers
I think I may have exceeded my two
minute limit but I will conclude my
comments at that and again I appreciate
the opportunity to speak thank you Jason
representative Dan McGuire has a
question so um I'm not ready to give up
on this one in the sense of elimination
I'm looking at this page we we got
there's only one state west of the
Mississippi that it licenses Foresters
California
uh the state of New York does not
license Foresters
um all of these states have have forests
right I mean
well not all of them but Oregon Oregon
and Washington too but Nebraska doesn't
have a lot of trees
or Nevada so
but again I think in New Hampshire with
Forester licensing
um and is it as chair chair mcquire had
mentioned earlier
this is woven into our tax policy this
is woven into regulatory policy
um current use and documented
stewardship requires a plan that's
approved by a licensed Forester in the
state of New Hampshire there are other
portions of Timber harvesting law that
have have requirements for licensed
Foresters and again as I had mentioned
um you know our our association when we
looked at this legislation and this
proposal for us it was very clear that
this is a
this this is a part of consumer
protection piece
so that I can't I can't just come up to
you and say yeah I've read some books on
forestry and I feel compelled
I feel uh I feel like I'm worthy of
managing this asset of yours and so we
felt that this was the set of very a
good important consumer protection
all right Jason thank you thank you
so again we will discuss this at our
work session either on Monday or Tuesday
of next week in room 212.
foreign